une production du studio sf bio venus
sans filtre présenté par caisse me le
podcast euros par lorsqu'on voit que
vous invitez clac ci-dessus ph quentin
avec moi habituellement d'hommes plantes
caisse me viennent tout juste de lancer
une deuxième collection estivale pour
souligner les belles couleurs de l'été
donc si vous attendiez une occasion en
or pour changer votre classement c'est
sûr et certain que dans la nouvelle
collection vous allez trouver ce qu'il
vous faut
tout ce qui vous représente bien plus
nouveauté chez keith mais maintenant
vous pouvez changer les couleurs d'un
même design donc vous a déjà fait la
couleur de fond qui vous représente le
mieux
on a un code promo pour vous c'est sans
filtre 20 pour 20% de rabais mais pour
cent de rabais ou il le 15 mai me disais
que l'offre très rarement 20% en fait si
vous voulez c'est le moment
sinon cette semaine on reçoit martin
gilbert qui est un chercheur en éthique
de l'intelligence artificielle
on a parlé moins fait le premier livre
que j'ai lu quand je suis devenu vegan
sait comment voir son style comme un
animal mort par march bail en fait ce
livre a changé ma vie donc c'est un
éthicien que s'intéresse s'est intéressé
à la question du véganisme donc on a
parlé évidemment de ça parce que vous
savez que c'est un sujet qui est cher
ici au sans filtre podcasts et on a
aussi parlé de l'éthique
en tout ce qui a trait à l'intelligence
artificielle donc comment programmer les
robots martin qui vient de sortir aller
qui s'appelle faire la morale aux robots
qui traite exactement de ce sujet là
donc si vous aimez c'est un petit peu la
philo
si qu il ya des questions vraiment
intéressante d'éthique qui sont posées
durant ce podcast leur puis ça nous aide
à mieux réfléchir sur le futur parce que
ça va ça vous en faites le véganisme et
l'intelligence artificielle risque de
faire beaucoup plus partie du futur donc
une super conversation on espère que
vous allez aimer ça autant que nous pis
puis c'est sûr bon écoute mais justement
remercier nous commencerons le podcast
cette semaine et présenté par un vive
vivre vous les connaissez c'est des
partenaires de longue date sans filtre
pas de casque cd smoothie déjeuner qui
sont congelés cd lunch rapide complet
qui sont congelés également super simple
à faire et ce qui est cool avec leur
smoothie c'est qu'ils peuvent se faire
en pop c'est comme vous savez que les
journées sont chaudes présentement
et quoi de mieux qu'un petit peuple
c'est qu'on sente et nutritifs pour se
rafraîchir donc je les teste et chez
nous avec le smoothie touk touk fait que
on va les voir
j'ai pris un smoothie toc toc 2e f
je les nie dans l'eau je suis un peu
perso gymnase un mot le port ce code qui
check and atteint ce que ça donne
c'est tellement de la bande c'est
tellement labeaume a apprécié va faire
chaud aujourd'hui c'est parfait fait
vrai meilleure façon de consommer vos
smoothies et on a même une offre
exclusive pour vous qui est 15 pour
simple sur deux outils gratuits en
utilisant le code promo sans filtre 15
en un mot dirigez-vous vers le bit ly
slash 2 us et y t4 n donc but liberté
point elle y slash 2 us et y t4 aisne
puis utilisez le code promo sans filtre
15 pour 15 % de rabais de smoothie
gratuit c'est le temps c'est le temps
d'y aller c'est le temps d'essayer merci
la gang de réveiller le podcast cette
semaine et présenté par nos amis chez
mindscape que vous connaissez bien
on se répète souvent mais même crime
c'est vraiment des produits qu'on
utilise au quotidien
en fait oui au quotidien parce que
justement c'est pas juste des produits
pour l'entretien sous la ceinture c'est
aussi des produits cosmétiques
moi j'utilise le parfum we find de
mindscape puis je reçois énormément plus
possible me vanter un petit peu mais pas
100 % je reçois énormément commentaires
positifs quant à mon odeur depuis que
j'utilise ce parfum le puis j'avais pas
qu'un parfum pouvait devenir vraiment fr
parties prenantes de ma personne puis
depuis que j'ai découvert le parfum we
find minsk et j'adore ça on a également
le perfect paquet de 4.0 que vous
connaissez ça vient avec le lendemain
4.0 waterproof tu veux pas te [ __ ] les
bases avec ça c'est parfait tu peux
l'amener avec toi des boxeurs qui
empêche les pôles incarner un des deux
raisons un petit brive a river pour
amener la fraîcheur sous la ceinture
tous se est disponible sur leur site web
et si vous utilisez le code sans filtre
en un mot vous avez 20 % de rabais et le
shipping gratuit fonctionne offre
incroyable
si vous voulez vous procurer que ce soit
le préfet ctaq et 4.0 le parfum ou
n'importe quel autre produit chez
mindscape allez voir ça
puis assurez vous d'utiliser un col
comme ça ils vont savoir que c'est nous
qui vous envoie merci minsk
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
certains jeux barge au balo merci
beaucoup d'être là comme je disais
rompuy en fait que je décrivais en
message c'est ton tournée s'est soulevée
ganis mon fils me consolider dans ma
tête le
mon nouveau mode de vie si on veut puis
je voudrais qu'en fait qu'on reporte
c'est la base avec toi par rapport à ton
cheminement toi que ce soit on va
évidemment parler d'intelligence
artificielle dendal dans le poker c'est
sûr mais par rapport à la philosophie
puis après ça commence ici transitionner
vers les tic comment les tic qui les
tchèques animal est arrivé dans l'enjeu
et tout et tout le temps donc chez qui
on peut partir de loin mais est-ce que
ce qui est toujours une fascination pour
la philosophie
je pense que j'ai toujours eu des
questions un peu un peu profondes a
comme comme beaucoup d'adolescents
d'adolescentes des trucs sur le sens de
la vie et puis j'avais j'avais aussi je
pense
avant avant même de faire de la avant
même la philo j'avais juste une
curiosité générale t je veux comprendre
comment le monde fonctionne moins six
mois les enfants les enfants pour des
questions très philosophique le moignon
le pas de plus le petit à petit plus on
vieillit en fait non c'est sûr qu'il ya
quelque chose de de fascinant de se
poser des questions même très simple
métaphysique là pourquoi y at il quelque
chose plutôt que rien après mon parcours
en fait je j'avais plutôt envie d'aller
jeter un bon élève l'apa excellent
excellent mais quand même un bon élève
je pouvais aller où je voulais j'avais
plutôt fait des sciences aux france au
lycée comme attendu du cégep et quand il
a fallu choisir un
quelque chose à l'université j'avais un
peu le goût d'aller en lettres parce que
j'ai mûri mais j'aimais quand même la
littérature aussi et puis j'avais ce
goût d'écrire sans doute déjà là mais je
me suis dit si je vais en j'ai pas
besoin d'aller en led pour me forcer à
lire des romans munitions saisies à ce
que c'était l'écriture ou la lecture
vraiment qui est l attrait des lettres
probablement probablement les deux
mais en tout cas comme comme je voulais
un peu de tout connaître tout savoir je
me suis dit baisse les livres de fiction
j'ai viré pour le plaisir par moi même
par contre quand eagle aristote platon
ça je sais que je ne vais pas dire pour
le plaisir dont nouvelle pour ça et puis
là je me suis rendu compte que j'avais
aussi du plaisir à lire des philosophes
et puis après il ya eu un un gros
changement c'est quand je suis venu donc
j'ai commencé mes études en france et
puis après j'ai je suis venu faire un
doctorat à l'université de montréal et
là j'ai découvert un autre pan de la
philo que ce que j'avais des coûts ce
que j'avais ce qu'on m'avait enseigné en
france qui est plutôt de la source qu'on
avait de la philo continentale avec très
proche de l'histoire de la la philo ici
ce que j'ai découvert c'est ce qu'on
appelle la philo analytique qui est un
peu plus la ride un peu moins
sexy au premier abord mais qui comme
plus précise et piqué c'est vraiment de
répondre aux questions et dans ce
domaine là même le domaine de la de
l'éthique donc dans lequel j'ai fait mon
doctorat l'éthique en gros c'est essayer
de répondre à la question quelle est la
bonne chose à faire
le bim a alors notamment le bien le mal
juste injuste le vertueux ou vicieux
aprilia il ya des théories des concepts
comme ça et est une une branche de
l'éthique c'est un peu différent et
c'est dans cette branche que j'ai fait
mon doctorat se rappelle la psychologie
morale là et ça c'est une distinction
super super importante là c'est comme
quand je donne un courte intro à
l'éthique c'est vraiment le premier truc
que j'essaye de bien faire comprendre
aux étudiants et aux étudiantes
c'est la différence entre eux et la
psychologie morale qui est la science
pour essayer de comprendre pourquoi les
gens ont les raisonnements moreau qu'ils
ont pourquoi les gens ont les intuitions
moral qu'ils ont qui sont qui sont
variables qui peuvent être biaisées par
un certain nombre de facteurs et puis ce
qu'on appelle les tic normatif qu'il a
essayé de comprendre que c'est quoi la
bonne chose à faire peu importe ce que
les gens pensent c'est quoi la bonne
chose à faire est donc il ya vraiment
ces deux trucs là qui m'intéressent d'un
côté et essayer de comprendre pourquoi
les gens à juste qu'un manager puis
après c'est ce que you et qu'est-ce qui
est ce qu'il ya des ddd direction claire
c'est ça ouais c'est ça notamment dans
des dilemmes et c'est donc le mon
premier livre qui était tiré de ma thèse
s'appelait l'imagination au moral donc
là c'est vraiment de la psychologie
morale vous essayez de vous montrer quel
était le rôle de l'imagination quand on
raisonne moralement et en fait pour
résumer en trois ou trois mots là on
utilise en particulier quand on fait de
l'empathie quand on se met à la place de
quelqu'un on utilise sont dans son
imagination ou à la place d'un animal on
peut utiliser son imagination aussi on
utilise quand on quand on fait des
comparaisons
entre comment les choses sont et puis
comment les choses pourraient être ou
quand on fait en philo en éthique on
fait beaucoup d'expériences de penser on
imagine des trucs efficaces
c'est une façon de raisonner puis on
utilise aussi dans les moins importants
là mais d'aller voir comme quand on on
voit un un visage dans un nuage nom peut
aussi y avoir des choses un peu de
stores là dans le raisonnement moral
pour pour de dire en deux mots ce qui a
précédé le le livre et après ce après ce
doctorat puis après ce livre là donc là
j'ai essayé d'appliquer d'une certaine
façon cette cette analyse du
raisonnement moral de la dilapidation
moral aux cadets au cas des animaux puis
à ce moment là mais tendant
personnellement dans ta vie est ce que
tu t'étais est ce qu est ce que tu étais
vegan day ce que tu avais eu en temps
mais une réflexion personnelle envers
ceux où c'est en présentant des
recherches tout en essayant d'appliquer
ces théories la quête avait apprises
pendant les recherches
non c'est c'est venu un peu à côté c'est
venu quand même assez tard donc ans
pendant que je faisais mon mon doctorat
c'est un peu venu de circonstance la
situation dans laquelle j'étais d'une
part une des doctorantes qui
travaillaient avec moi avec la même
directrice de thèse c'est valérie giroud
qui faisait qu'à une philosophe qui met
du poids à ses neuf
il faisait me taire un médecin qu'animal
ne faisait sa thèse sur ce sujet là et
donc quand elle avait fait une préface
vraiment deuxième livre de recettes
ok ouais donc ses succès sur temps
discutant avec les fichiers ouvre et si
j'essayais dû à mes petits contre les
appels à l'époque où j'étais je mangeais
de gt omnivore la map à porto devait
gagnent et donc en essayant un peu
d'argumenter avec est assez vite je
voyais que ça marchait pas
elle avait raison que tu avais
l'argument perben c'est ça c'est ça
après yes et c'est clair qu'il ya une
différence
il suffit pas de savoir que c'est la
bonne chose à faire et puis de s'y
mènent donc là ce qui est ce qu'il ya
beaucoup aidé c'est que ma conjointe
élise elle aussi elle a eu le même type
de d'intuition mal que moi mais en plus
elle peut à ce moment arrêtée je tiens
sans vie on habitait on habitait
ensemble et elle elle était plus motivé
que moi peut-être pour manger se lancer
dans un nouveau mode alimentaire et puis
même après plus généralement donc là la
transition s'est fait un peu de façon 1
indolore parce que j'étais vraiment bien
entouré et puis ça ça allait dans le
sens donc à l'afld
voilà j'ai commencé mon doctorat en
étant ni bord et je finis en étant vegan
et antispécistes passant les deux vont
ensemble et après le doctorat dont j'ai
fais le j'ai fait le livre j'ai essayé
d'appliquer c'est ça des connaissances
de psychologie morale à au cas
particulier des animaux et de notre
rapport aux animaux
j'aime que les débuts de tout ce chemin
je te dis je voulais tout savoir donc je
suis alger étudiant en philosophie est
ce qui s qui après avoir fait tout ce
chemin et lui conviendront vega naître
après m'être car après on fait tout ce
chemin et le qui quand même été une
succession d'événements qui a fait qu'il
était devenue payante écrit que tu as
écrite écrire ce livre le mais est-ce
que tu as l'impression d'être approché
de tout savoir où tu sais où tu as les
bressans qui ont encore plus à savoir
finalement que le projet mais ça met un
peu les deux messieurs c'est vrai que
c'est je pense une phrase de blaise
pascal le philosophe là qui dit le
canton savoir augmente en fait ton nom
savoir augmentent beaucoup plus c'est
comme si savoir c'était le rayon d'une
d'une sphère et puis le nom savoir c'est
la surface la sphère donc c'est un peu
vrai mais c'est quand même je me sens
quand même moins - ignorant que quand
j'étais
j'ai pas adolescents et surtout j'ai des
catégories plus clair en tête ne
serait-ce que cette distinction que j'ai
évoqué tantôt là entre le comment les
choses sont et comment les choses
devraient être entre la science et puis
d'éthique parce qu'en gros c'est ça la
science elle nous dit comment les choses
sont et puis les tic nous dit comment
les choses devraient être juste cette
distinction qui est assez simple en fait
ça me ça me semble que ça permet d'être
beaucoup plus conscients de 2,2 ce qui
est autour de nous la bon est ce que ces
deux sphères le la science et l'éthique
travaillent main dans la main ce que la
communication et bah si c'est trop
générales pour pour répondre à ça disons
que dans méthodes la méthode amis
l'universitaire ce qu'est ce qui est si
le département se parlent au ps qui
émettront des arguments scientifiques
sont tenues en compte au camp nou un
exercice de pensée philosophique ou mais
ça alors est-ce que les départements se
parle un peu il ya des étudiants de jeu
par d'ingénierie qui vont prendre des
cours d'éthique des étudiants de
biologie qui prennent des cours
d'éthique
donc il ya quand même une certain
mélange peas et c'est important là parce
que l'éthique c'est un peu un truc
transversale toutes disciplines tout
métier tout tout corps professionnel
peut se poser des questions éthiques sur
comment est ce que est ce que je fais
bien ou pas des podcasts à ce que je
fais bien moi et c'est donc en ce sens
cela tout le monde a un peu besoin de
d'éthique après sur la question des
arguments est ce que est ce que la
science apporte des éléments dans les
réflexions éthiques
oui mais simplement comme contrainte
parce que la science elle va jamais te
dire qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
la science elle te dis comment pense que
les choses sont elles essayent de faire
un modèle plus le plus précis possible
mais donc il ya toujours un moment un
saut dès qu'on passe à comment les
choses devraient être qu'est ce qu'on
devrait faire est ce que c'est bien ou
mal de faire ceci
mais on va pouvoir trouver de réponse
dans la science la science elle fait
juste posé d
des contraintes quoi en disant ça c'est
juste ça si tu voulais faire ceci c'est
juste pas possible parce que il ya des
contraintes physiques mais elle dit pas
si c'est bien ou mal mais des fois on
imagine qu'une réponse scientifique peut
mener à une réflexion éthique
si je prends l'exemple des l'exemple
animal parce que parce que c'est loin de
ce qu on parle ne le sait vraiment de ce
que je suis plus outillés pour parler en
termes de flux de fil lorsque la
sentience éprouvés scientifiquement
l'éthique peut s'emparer de 7,7
ce vélo pour aller ensuite établir une
ligne des tic
tout à fait c'est en fait ce que
squelettiques dit mettons donc dans le
cadre là la sentience qui est la
capacité de ressentir d'éprouver du
plaisir et de la peine c'est que quand
un être quand une entité animal robots
extraterrestres peu importe éprouvent
des choses est capable de ressentir du
plaisir ou de la douleur alors ça
devient ce qu'on appelle un patient
moral ça devient une entité envers qui
on a minimalement d'aider certains de
voir le voir ne pas torturer
éventuellement de patu etc
et quand est ce que fait la science
c'est qu'elle nous dit est checké cette
entité là
mettant les poissons c'est relativement
récent qu'on a des bonnes données sur la
sentience des poissons les poissons
ressentent la douleur donc là l'éthicien
arrivent en disant ben s'ils ressentent
la douleur alors on doit en tenir compte
dans la façon dont on dit il avec eux
peut-être ne pas les péchés ou ne pas
les manger ou des choses comme ça donc
oui là il ya un dialogue d'une certaine
façon entre la science et puis les tic
est ce que parce que comme la science
n'est pas toujours écoutés par les ceux
qui sont en position prise de décision
notamment tous conseils par exemple sur
les données sur les lits les effets
environnementaux de deux plans
d'affaires en fait dans nos sociétés
puisque les lois sont pas nécessairement
appliquée est ce que l'éthique est aussi
souvent aussi du revers de la main par
les les preneurs de décisions et les
tickets hélène elle atteint que 1
directement les les preneurs de
décisions en fait pour être vraiment
efficace l'éthique il faut qu elle ce
qu'elle devienne du droit d'une certaine
façon mais un gars comme il ya plusieurs
il ya plusieurs étages
donc les décideurs politiques que c'est
par l'intermédiaire souvent du droit qui
font avancer la société
l'éthique c'est plutôt pour chacun et
tout le monde quand on se demande qu'est
ce que tu l affaire est correct ou pas
ouais qu'est ce qui en fait qu'est-ce
qui t'a amené va satisfaire lequel était
la philosophie si tu penses que tu
observé il y avait une lacune autour de
tes dents dans le monde à ce niveau le
sou c'est plus un intérêt personnel
était au départ c'était très très lisse
la cité c'était même quasiment parce que
je connaissais c'était un peu le domaine
que je connaissais le moins me suis dit
ah ouais on va on va aller voir jouer
dans la curiosité au boudin après avoir
un peu étudiée puis en découvrant la
psychologie morale là j'ai vraiment
capote est tellement je trouvais ça
intéressant là parce que c'est
on commence à savoir des choses sur la
façon dont les humains juge ce qui est
bien et ce qui est mal pour quelles
raisons et c'est vraiment passionnant
puisque des travaux des travaux récents
on peut mettre des scans pire pour faire
poser des questions à quelqu'un puis
regardez dans le scan quelle partie de
son cerveau traite un problème moral
donc là il y avait vraiment ma curiosité
était très très excité et puis je me
suis rendu compte que oui c'était
important que finalement c'était
peut-être la partie de la philosophie
qui était la plus importante parce que
elle elle peut avoir des applications
très concrètes dans
dans la vie alors que ce soit dans la
façon dont on s'alimente avec des
considérations éthiques animal mais dans
dans beaucoup beaucoup d'autres
dimensions de la vie donc traite de
l'éthique c'est vraiment intéressant
je sais j'ai l'impression que c'est des
questions c'est l'éducation qui qui qui
qui arrête jamais en fait c'est parce
que justement les soit les nouvelles
technologies ou soit avec les nouvelles
données scientifiques je demande
toujours besoin de repenser avec ces
nouvelles contraintes le le bien le malt
et puis qui était aussi mettons c'est
intéressant mais trop de lire platon
peut se demander est-ce que c'est ce que
l'âme et était mortel chez platon tipi
c'est un exercice de pensée qu'il phone
sauf que en bout de ligne beaucoup de
philosophes qui ont essayé de répondre à
des questions qui est que maintenant
justement la science est capable de
répondre tandis que les tic la science
pour gérer tous comme on disait tantôt
thabo décrire très précisément comment
sont les choses c'est quoi les lois qui
implique tel tel effet ça te dira pas si
c'est si c'est bien ou mal
ouais donc puis est ce qui est
maintenant face j'imagine que oui mais
face à une même situation wang hao même
dilemme éthique tu parlais de
d'électrodes qui permettent de voir
comment ton cerveau réagit est-ce que
les les êtres humains pas des électrodes
des scans des scans dans les scans
qu'est ce que les êtres humains a réagi
de la même façon une même question
j'imagine comment dénoncer ça il ya des
idées il ya des différences intéressant
mais on peut faire un test
le scanner mais pour vous donner un
exemple très classique de 2 de dilemme
moral qui sert à essayer de comprendre
les intuitions des gens ont volé paient
déjà entendu parler là mais c'est là le
dilemme du tramway donc expérience de
pensée il ya un tramway qui s'avance
sans frein et qui va écraser cinq
personnes genre des travailleurs qui ont
des casques sur la tête par hypothèse on
va dire qu'ils vont mourir si le tramway
les les écrase il ne voit pas venir mais
il ya une option c'est qu'il ya une voie
secondaire
et vous avez la possibilité d'actionner
vous êtes à l'extérieur
vous avez la possibilité d'actionner le
levier qui va envoyer le tramway sur
cette voie secondaire et là
malheureusement il ya une personne qui
est dans la même situation
donc le la question que je vous pose et
puis qu'on compose d'un style
d'expérience et quelle est la bonne
chose à faire dans cette situation
laisser les choses aller et avoir cinq
morts ou actionner le levier et puis
avoir un mort en général
l'intuition ces deux d'actionner le
levier du canton demande justifiée c'est
assez simple c'est de dire on minimise
le nombre de morts donc ça on l'a on
fait appel à un raisonnement qu'on peut
qualifier d' utilitariste c'est la
théorie morale qui disent qu'il faut
faire c'est essayer de hawx doit
augmenter le bien-être au diminué qui
est un calcul on le fait de quelques
cessions d'actifs le plus objectivement
possible
c'était l'action vaut procurer tard de
bien à tant de personnes vers ce jeu
d'action exactement et alors des
situations peuvent parfois le calcul est
simple parfois si on veut vraiment faire
le calcul aux fins et puis c'est pour ça
que lüthi tarifs devient compliqué il
faudrait même imaginer les conséquences
à long terme quand même à très long
terme si on veut vraiment tout mettre
dans la balance
et donc là la situation est telle
qu'elle est pilates simplifie la même
personne - tout le monde tout le monde
ou à des personnes en tout cas on n'a
pas d'informations sur les branches
situées dilemme numéro deux variantes
cette fois ci il ya toujours le tramway
qui s'apprête à écraser les cinq
personnes et puis il n'y a pas de voie
secondaire mais il ya un pont au-dessus
de la voie
et puis il ya une personne un badaud qui
regardent le paysage et par hypothèse on
assume que si vous poussez cette
personne elle va tomber sur le sur les
rails et elle va arrêter le train et
elle va mourir et palais saint caprais
et là quand on est donc est-ce que c'est
correct de pousser là la personne a
comme vous vous en doutez l'intuition
majoritaire est assez différente parce
que si on était utilitariste re comme
tantôt on devrait répondre que c'est
qu'il faut la pousser mais on a comme
une
on a un autre type d'intuition keep up
dans notre cerveau est là c'est ce qu'on
a appelé une impulsion plus
déontologique qui consiste à dire il ya
des choses qu'il faut pas faire puis là
on ne peut pas on peut pas tuer le
personne qui a rien demandé
parce que c'est comme ancrée dans notre
cerveau et donc ça quand on veut quand
on fait passer des cantons pose ces
questions à des gens qui sont dans des
scans dans des études de
neuropsychologie moral on se rend compte
que dans le cas numéro un c'est la zone
du calcul qui effectivement en barque et
puis les gens font le fond de calculs et
puis voilà là le moindre coup là c'est
de sauver dans le dans l'autre cas c'est
pas la zone du calcul c'est plus une
zone émotionnel donc c'est une sorte de
flash qui te dire leur nom tu peux pas
faire tu veux pas faire ça
pourtant comme quand on y réfléchit
d'activer le levier c'est exactement la
même action que de les diffuser la
personne sauf qu'il ya quelque chose de
plus direct dans l'action de pousser
dans le web on le ferait mais un peu
différemment dans notre cerveau mais en
tout cas c'est ça permet surtout de voir
que parfois on a des intuitions
un peu en contre contradictoire et c'est
pour ça que là on peut avoir besoin de
philosophie morale d'éthique pour
essayer de mettre de l'ordre et puis de
clarifier quelques sur quelle théorie
jma je m'appuie ou est-ce que je
justifie alors évidemment il ya eu
beaucoup beaucoup d'articles de philo
qui ont été écrits betty qui a été écrit
sur sur ces fameux dilemme pour essayer
justement de donner de la cohérence à
tout ça mais bon il
il en reste qui a quand même deux de
grandes façon d'aborder les dilemmes du
tramway puis même plus généralement les
tic sa une à une approche qu'on appelle
déontologique où il s'agit de respecter
certaines certaines règles morales du
type tu ne tueras point
et puis une approche qu'on appelle
utilitariste qu'un sous-ensemble du
conséquentialiste mme qui elles disent
qu'il faut faire d'annoncé c'est
regarder les conséquences donc le
déontologie ce midi il faut respecter
certaines règles peu importe les
conséquences
et puis le ti dit harris de dire non non
non il faut regarder les conséquences
puis si dans les conséquences et plein
de morts peut-être qu'il faut pas qu'il
faut rompre sa promesse ou qu'il faut
faut faire faut aller à l'encontre de
règlement et en éthique animal on a ces
deux types de
de raisonnement qui peuvent aussi qu'ils
peuvent aussi embarqué pour com comment
est-ce que se manifeste alors je dirais
que
voici on rentre dans les dents les
arguments en faveur du véganisme telles
que je les expose dans le voir son steak
comme un animal mort donc il ya
plusieurs types d'arguments il ya des
arguments de type plutot santé il ya des
arguments environnementaux puis à des
arguments éthiques animal est ce que
parce que je suis passé par un chacun on
garde une trêve sur l'éthique animale
bon on peut on pleurait sur les deux
c'est que l'on soit on fait pas
nécessairement une fois on expose une
série donc en éthique en gros il ya deux
façons de moi je présente souvent disant
qu'il ya deux façons d'argumenter il ya
un espèce dalian
il ya un premier argument qui est plutôt
de nature utilitariste qui va dire mais
si on peut éviter de faire
du tort du mal à un être sensible
alors on devrait si on veut faire sans
que ça nous coûte
mal équivalent à côté le calcul
utilitariste
nous indiquons on devrait minimiser la
douleur et puis ben voila si on peut
manger un very big air à la place d'un
burger le calcul utilitariste dit qu'il
faut il faut manger le lever geiberger
ce moment qu'on accepte de rentrer les
animaux dans ce calcul
pascal que des questions calcul juste le
bonheur humain fait évidemment que la
réponse concernant la viande c'est bon
dessus mais si on ajoute les animaux
dans ce calcul lui qui sont je connais
pas les chiffres mais sans doute plus
nombreux et les humains mais ça fait pas
tout à fait et aimer c'est pour les
philosophes utilitariste est très
légitime de faire rentrer les animaux
parce que ce que ce que disent les
philosophes utilitariste comme jeremy
bentham par exemple en anglais du 19e
c'est que où est ce qu'il faut faire
c'est maximiser le bien-être mais toute
entité qu'est capable de
plaisir humaine doit doit intervenir
entrer là dedans puis si on peut
spéculer on veut spéculer sur un truc
très différents les robots mais temps si
on fabriquer des robots capables de
ressentir le plaisir et la douleur il
faudrait en tenir compte d'un point de
vue utilisatrices et puis peut-être pas
en fabriquer pour pas produire de la la
douleur et de la douleur et de groen
ouais c'est souvent ce genre de huawei
ça c'est beaucoup utilisé en science
fiction et fit alors l'autre l'autre
approche la déontologie qu'elle va pas
tant insisté sur la douleur que sur des
questions de de droit et de
discrimination et là elle va dire en
gros bas dans le cas des dans le cas des
êtres humains
on pense que c'est mal de de discriminer
les hommes et les femmes on pense que
c'est mal de discriminer les gens selon
leur origine ethnique
donc le le sexisme le racisme ne sont
normalement pas acceptable et bien sûr
un peu sur ce modèle on peut développer
la notion de spécisme qui est l'idée
d'une discrimination fondée sur donc on
parle le sexe ou le spasme et sur
l'espèce est donc là en gros là
l'argument qui consiste à dire si la
seule explication à la discrimination
que tu fais en verve
si si si ta seule raison de manger du
cochon c'est de dire ben oui je le
traite mal parce qu'il n'appartient pas
à l'espèce humaine il appartient à
l'espèce cochon 1
si l'écossais ont peu de droits
fondamentaux la saison si tu manges des
cochons s'est passé qui n'ont pas de
danse ils avaient des droits
fondamentaux probablement qu'ils
auraient droit de ne pas être mangé quoi
que de rester en vie donc oui la vie des
c'est il ya une discrimination injuste
fondée sur
sur l'espèce qui est analogue à des
discriminations injuste fondée sur
d'autres propriété littéraire est donc
là cette notion de discrimination
injuste elle est plutôt du côté
d'intuition déontologique il y a jallet
va l'aborder en fait c'est les aime ces
droits fondamentaux le t on une
intuition souvent qu'on nous dit on ne
doit pas discriminant de pau faire du
mal à autrui
les humains ont une dignité de base mais
comment sipa par les calculs
utilitariste comment qu'on y trouve
comment qu'on y trouve ses lois le de la
déontologie du 6 mai on peut les mettons
l'ailé pour les humains on pourrait dire
qu'une phase les dix commandements
donc là ça vient d'eux ça vient de dieu
aussi long mais si on croit en dieu cdc
des commandements déontologique il faut
qu'il faut respecter
mais à partir de là disons pour
l'éthique animale
il n'y a pas nécessairement besoin de
démontrer que
dieu a dit ceci ou cela ou qu'il ya des
principes grave et quelque part il ya
juste besoin de dire ok ben on a avec
les humains les humains on leur donne
tel était le droit les animaux on leur
donne aucun aucun droit alors si on
regarde à quoi sert le droit les droits
ça sert à protéger les intérêts
fondamentaux l'intérêt a pas être
maltraités l'intérieur a pas être tué
l'intérêt de vivre l intérêt à être en
liberté a peut être apparaître en cache
donc ça pour les humains a aucun
problème à considérer que c'est des
intérêts fondamentaux importants puisque
c'est correct d'avoir des droits pour
protéger sa mais comment ça se fait que
quand on passe aux animaux c'est
intéressant semble 10 disparaître alors
qu'ils sont là c'est sûr qu'un animal en
cage il a intérêt à il aura envie d'être
en liberté ils n'auraient pas il n'a pas
envie d'être tué il n'a pas envie d'être
maltraités attache etc mais hélas la
seule explication que les gens semblent
avoir c'est à dire maintenant il
appartient à une autre espèce
mais ça c'est du souci la seule
explication c'est qu'ils appartiennent à
une autre espèce et du cedus précise et
donc pour pour justifier les droits les
droits fondamentaux il ya il ya un
auteur qui s'appelle tom reagan qui va
dire baisser dès l'instant que on peut
dire qu'un un être sensible et sujet
d'une vie donc il a un peu comme un
humain qu'il est qu'ils éprouvent des
choses qu'il a
qui a le monde a du sens pour lui et
puis sur b surtout pic il a encore une
fois cette sentience la capacité de
d'éprouver du plaisir la douleur des
émotions
on devrait le considérer comme un
patient moral au sens fort comme et du
coup un sujet de droit moral est donc
l'accord accordé des droits fondamentaux
il ya sur cette question des droits
fondamentaux peut être un truc est plus
intuitif encore que j'aime bien rappeler
qui vient d'un juriste et philosophe
américain qui s'appelle guérif
fonctionne c'est la notion de propriété
en fait ce que dit gary franson c'est
qu'il suffirait de qu'il ya un droit
qu'on il suffirait de conférer à aux
animaux pour régler la situation du
point de vue moral et légal
ça serait de dire que les animaux ne
peuvent plus être des propriétés privées
que les animaux peuvent pas être achetés
et vendus comme on achète et on vend de
la bière des maisons des chats etc et
et alors intuitivement c'est ça il ya
quand même quelque chose oui un animal
n'est pas une marchandise là c'est pas
c'est pas la même chose un grille pain
et puis un chat un chien ou un cochon
sauf que du point de vue légal
alors ça c'est un peu bougé en 2015 à la
suite d'un manifeste que j'avais
lancée avec élise dernier jeu long de la
spéciale et puis sophie gaillard qui
était aussi qui est aussi avocat t'as la
spéciale les animaux ne sont pas des
choses donc ça c'est un peu bougé pas
cela juridiquement les animaux sont un
peu sont sortis de là qu'a t il sont
plus dans la même catégorie que les la
bière et puis la grippe a mais c'est ça
en pratique en pratique l'industrie
l'industrie de la viande c'est acheter
un animal vivant et puis vendre de la
viande morte quoi et donc tout repose
sur la propriété ici et on peut pas
faire le lien avec les cela va je
croyais en a pas si longtemps les êtres
humains sans en acheter en vendée
d'autres pour les pour les exploiter
alors aujourd'hui dans le cas des êtres
humains tout le monde est d'accord pour
dire que c'est inacceptable
mais n'empêche que dans le cas des
animaux on a on a l'impression que c'est
encore acceptable mais je pense en fait
que beaucoup de gens réalisent pas
premièrement il beaucoup d'aveuglément
volontaire puis de jus de normes qui
s'annonce critique mais je pense aussi
qu est il ya une espèce de 10 des
classes en sciences est surestimée
peut-être où on n'estime pas on n'est
pas des gens ne réalisent pas en fait
l'étendue de la sentience de chez les
cochons chez les vaches ou parce que
c'est quand même quelque chose qui est
qui qui qui qui qui de l'autre probable
de la science de pouvoir le prouver
puis après ce gie magie ne suis pas
expert mais c'est que la conscience d'un
cochon et pendant même temps sens d'une
truite qui promène son sens que c'est un
espèce de de gradation le tissu sport et
de la plante après ceux de la la coque
réel jusqu'à jusqu'au cochon le tiche
j'imagine quelle espèce de ligne puis
après amnesty sur tissu requis une ligne
c'est à dire que des entités qui sont
pas sentis en danger quand tu dis là la
plante là non on n'a pas de bonnes
raisons de penser que les plans de son
100ème les insectes on sait pas trop là
où on est sûr c'est pour les vertébrés
donc les animaux qu'une colonne
vertébrale ça inclut les manies faire
les oiseaux les poissons
notamment parce que c'est le boulot si
dense que c'est oui et non du point de
vue est ce que s'en tient au oui oui ça
c'est binaire soit une entité senti en
soit les parkings après sur la la elle
s'en tient ça veut dire être sensive
donc éprouvé des choses sur la qualité
ou la quantité de ce qui est prouvé là
il ya sans doute des différences et on
peut penser que au cerveau de l'insecte
s'ils sont si sont sentis an ou de
poisson très simple il ya un peu moins
de 2 d'information et de douleur qui
passe mais encore c'est quand même
spéculatifs pipi en fait je me gêne que
de dire oui mais ressent moins de
douleur économiquement c'est valable ou
non compris enfants mais c'est ça le
truc c'est qu'on l'ait on est en conflit
d'intérêts est là dès l'instant où on
les mange de l'instant on les exploite
ouais c'est plus simple de se dire que
le poisson il ressent rien où il ressent
presque rien pour tentons en temps
régulier sur le sur le barbecue
et ça c'est des trucs de psychologie
mort ajustements à s'y essayer d'étudier
comment l'être humain seulement un peu à
lui même pour servir son propre son
propre intérêt il ya une expérience que
je raconte dans le voir sont secs comme
un animal mort qui est un peu
l'expérience qui m'a fait dire ok oui là
il ya vraiment du judas il ya des choses
intéressantes à aller chercher
c'est une expérience que l expérience
des moutons qui a été fait en australie
au début des années 2010
donc là entendu des personnes au hasard
c'est une expérience de psychologie
sociale et puis on fait deux groupes au
hasard puis il ya un groupe à qui on
montre une photo de moutons et puis a
marqué dessous ce bouton va être envoyé
à l'abattoir et sera bientôt disponible
dans un supermarché précise près de chez
vous quoi quelque chose comme ça puis à
l'autre groupe
on entre la même photo et puis avec une
autre légende qui dit ce mouton va
passer le reste de sa vie avec d'autres
moutons et mourir de sa mort de moutons
et et ensuite on demande aux gens des
deux groupes d'évaluer les capacités
cognitives du mouton qui sont hélas ce
qu'on voit c'est que les gens à qui on a
dit que le mouton allait être tués pour
être mangés par ea ou plus ou moins ont
tendance à attribuer moins de capacité
cognitive quelques l'autre groupe
pourquoi parce que c'est ça qu'on
appelle une dissonance cognitive ou
qu'on appelle aussi parfois le paradoxe
de la viande mais la plupart des gens
ont quand même une certaine empathie
pour les animaux les enfants les dessins
animés excédera et puis en même temps
ils consomment la plupart des gens ils
consomment des animaux et évidemment il
ya un truc ça ça fait paradoxe parce que
et mais l'animal et puis aimé le steak à
moins de neuf au quai de l'abattoir au
milieu et c'est pas très aimable pour le
pour l'animal met donc c'est ça les gens
les gens du coup utilisent des
stratégies pour un peu se déculpabiliser
si on veut et une de ces stratégies ça
consiste à faire ce rappel la dea
mentalisation donc à se persuader que
l'animal qu'on consomme en l'occurrence
est moins malins souffrent moins
- conscient bien on voit bien aussi
quand on fait des quand on demande aux
gens d'évaluer les capacités mentales
des animaux selon qu'ils sont sauvages
ou animaux
enfin j de compagnie ou qu'on consomme
ya vraiment des ya plusieurs catégories
d'animaux ben voilà les anis et c'est
clair que les animaux de compagnie
chiens chats alors là ça va ça dépend
des pays bas mais dans les pays où les
chiens et les chats sont des animaux de
compagnie les gens attribuent des autres
capacités mentales mêmes font facilement
de l'empathie avec leur leurs animaux
les animaux de consommation là on va
avoir tendance à
dcb seller leurs capacités et les
animaux sauvages
si on les consomme pas on peut comme un
peu avoir une vision que plus ou moins
objectives en tout cas c'est pas biaisé
par notre part notre intérêt mais donc
genre animal équivalent je sais pas ce
qui serait l'équivalent du cochon voilà
le sens peut-être
spontanément on va attribuer plus de
capacité cognitive au sanglier sauvage
coco chants qu'on consomme est pareil
cochon chiens cochons chien c'est faux
c'est frappant les gens attribuent
beaucoup plus de capacités cognitives
aux chiens cochons alors corps en
réalité les cochons serait plutôt plus
plus intelligents que les prix sont
vraiment capables de faire les choses
très très très très surprenante
dans cet exemple précis l'heure mais je
me rappelle dans ton essai y avait eu un
exercice
un exercice morale que tu poses est
qu'ils étaient pour sur allier corée
joie ce film me trompe le mérite est de
dire si on me demandait avant de manger
du chocolat c'est un amateur de chocolat
si on me demandait avant de manger de
chocolat est ce que tu irais danton sous
sol pour couper le museau d'un chiot
alors que des tests au sol et
remplissent chômé qu'avant chaque fois
que tu devais manger du chocolat et des
descendants bas coupez le museau de
chiots pourvoir profiter de ta barre de
chocolat
est-ce que tu le ferais mais je pense
que c'est quelque chose qui ressemble à
ça c'est une expérience de pensée c'est
pour les c'est pour les gens qui disent
qu'ils répondent
ouais comme objets qui font une
objection au véganisme un désarroi et
non mais c'est un goût qui est
irremplaçable ou de la viande et je peux
pas me passer de ce goût là je peux pas
le retrouver ailleurs
et le fait que ce soit irremplaçable ça
justifie les jeunes sur dix ans voilà
voilà
et donc là il ya un philosophe qui
s'appelle alasdair nord croft si je me
souviens bien qui fait cette expérience
de pensée en disant ma supposons que
quelqu'un est là c'est assez folle mais
elle est belle c'est exprime sa pensée
supposons qu'il ya quelqu'un il a eu un
accident puis dans son cerveau il a
perdu le goût du chocolat puis l'état
[ __ ] quelqu'un qui trippent et
chocolat vraiment c'était comme le très
très important dans sa vie le boulot
qu'on pourrait dire quand il remplaça
exacte et et puis là en faisant des
recherches il se rend compte maintenant
il ya une façon pour lui de retrouver le
goût du chocolat c'est s'injecter un
sérum particulier qui a obtenu en
torturant des chiots donc dans sa cave
il a d un élevage de chiots qui torture
ne va pas basculer leur rue du mal à ça
l'ennuie un peu mais ils aiment
tellement chocolat qui veut retrouver ce
goût donc il est il les tortures il
s'injecte le truc est là il a le goût du
chocolat et donc l'expérience de pensée
nous dit ok ce cas qu'est ce qu'on pense
à nous de cette personne là est ce qu'on
pense qu'elle est justifiée à consommer
à torturer les chiots pour une question
gustatives et évidemment la plupart des
gens vont dire non c'est ça tant pis
quoi tant pis pour le goût de chocolat
ça justifie pas de torturer des chiots
mais évidemment voilà on peut transposer
ça à toutes les personnes qui dirait moi
mon argument c'est là un argument
gustatif plus beaucoup y aurait d'autres
façons de contesté l'argument
aujourd'hui c'est que iata de la bouffe
vegan qui goûte aussi bon que là
que la vraie viande entre guillemets
puis sans parler de la viande cellulaire
d'avion et tout ça mais donc c'était
c'était ça leur arrive ma parce que moi
je me rappelle quand j'avais lu ce jeu
me fait retrouver dans une impasse
c'est un tournage l'impasse puisque pipi
c'est est ce parce que c'est sûr en fait
ce qu est ce qu on dit depuis tout à
l'heure par rapport aux mécanismes c'est
sûr que quelqu'un qui est confronté
vraiment qui est honnête envers son
propre raisonnement va se retrouver dans
une impasse
qu'on le veuille ou pas fake qu'est ce
qui fait que tout le monde que ce
raisonnement là je leur montre qu'ils
nous écoutent c'est sûr qu'ils sont qui
se retrouve jamais de la vie je vais
torture et les chiots pour pour décoller
alors qu'actuellement on torture des
départs pour ce qui pour quelque chose
que tu manges quand même qu'est ce qui
fait qu'on est capable de distancer
comme ça parce que moi je les fais
longtemps longtemps sachant qu est ce
qui se passait moi aussi
ouais moi aussi j'ai été plus longtemps
dans ma vie là je prendrai été plus
longtemps non vegan plus loin que vegan
date
bon ben là c'est des explications
rentrer dans la psychologie sociale on
pourrait se poser des questions un peu
analogue sur je sais pas qu'est ce qui
fait que les gens sont sexistes des gens
sont racistes dont on sait que les
hommes et les femmes devraient être égal
que on ne devrait pas discriminer selon
le soleil justement par rapport à ce
titre nous on est quand même en comme on
aime bien le les auditeurs de notre
podcast on juge qui sont des gens qui
aiment réfléchir quand même se poser les
questions qui sont pas fondamentalement
raciste c'est ce qu'on a compris qu'il
sait en jeu le son sont nécessaires à
combattre mais que mais il ya quelque
chose qui peut il ya quelque chose qui
n'est pas au même niveau avec les
animaux on dirait c'est une culture elle
s'est tue parce que on est c'est dans
l'histoire des mouvements progressistes
là parce que pour moi ça s'inscrit c'est
un mouvement progressiste de libéra cité
le livre de peter singer en soit son
opération s'appelle libération animale
c'est un peu le modèle sur le modèle de
libération des femmes libération des
noirs et etc donc oui c'est un peu là le
mouvement de libération le plus récent
qui est très particulier parce que dans
les autres mouvements libération c'est
les personnes qui l'ont pressé clients
elle même la parole là là c'est pas
laissez pas les animaux directement qui
est qui s'exprime là c'est des humains
qui agissent en leur nom
donc ça c'est probablement une partie de
l'explication
il ya il ya aussi bêtement le poids des
habitudes c'est à dire que
nos parents nos grands parents
mangez pas si on est pas ce qu il faut
aussi savoir que des sociétés en inde il
ya des sociétés végétarienne ou là on
aurait on n'aurait pas ça puis s'est
fait beaucoup plus facile de convaincre
les gens d'arrêter de manger des animaux
c'est culturel mais dans d'un dea dans
des sociétés où il ya une culture de
pete non seulement il ya une culture de
manger des animaux mais c'est même
valorisé en fait c'est valoriser parce
que historiquement c'était plutôt les
riches qui mangeaient des animaux en
tous cas arrivent régulièrement pas
cessé c'est plus plus long à produire
bon xxème siècle il y a
l'élevage en masse qui se développe donc
là tout le monde peut manger des pistes
m ca s'inverse même quasiment la plus
quasiment plus les gens sont pauvres
pluies vont consommer de mauvaises
souvent nos visions deviennent trop
grasse et c'est en tout cas il ya une
industrie là qu'est la future qui ans
qui en donne qui en donne et
j'ai perdu mon résultat en fait en fait
l'idée puis peut-être que je vais
relancer la question avec une autre sous
conditions qu'en est il de la map que
j'avais cette discussion là avec gabriel
nadeau dubois qui se posait cette
question là parce que lui évidemment il
prône une diminution de la consommation
de viande mais pour des enjeux
environnementaux principalement mais lui
ce qu'il me disait c'est comment est ce
qu'on prend action pour pour un individu
qui ne peux pas parler pour lui même
pourquoi est-ce qu'on se donne le droit
de choisir de choisir qu'est ce qu'on
doit faire c'est là évidemment que c'est
les droits fondamentaux on peut quand
même deviner que le cochon il n'a pas
envie qu'on lui livre les dents quand on
lui coupe les testicules à froid quand
il est bébé quand les couples à queue
qui puisse pas les les truies on peut
deviner quel ont besoin de se retourner
et qu'elles sont pas et on peut deviner
aussi qu'ils ont passé les animaux qu'on
consomme ces des animaux bébé en fait
qu'ils sont ils sont mon client est roi
de vie au conte donc c'est ça c'est ça
me paraît pas un argument très très fort
en tout cas pour paul et pour les
questions fondamentales après sans doute
que oui est ce que mon chat savoir
exactement ce qu'il veut ce qui lui ce
qui lui ferait plaisir bon là ça peut
être plus
plus difficile mais disons que pour les
animaux qu'on exploit que c'est facile
de deville s'en rendre compte mais il
préférait ne pas être exploité
si on enlève complètement l'aspect
industriel la chose parce que
l'industriel je pense que une grande
majorité de la population voit ce qui se
passe dans l'abattoir industrielle ppi
est pas d'accord avec une méthode
l'exploitation compte itunes seront
commandés et continue de le faire quand
même quand tu ne le faire quand même
mais au moins une fois confronté à fait
c'est clair qu'est ce qui se passe avec
justement cesser ces élevages là qui
sont faits dans le respect des animaux
spa j'imagine que ça revient encore au
droit fondamental ne pas mourir à ma
femme ma fille oui mais minimalement il
ya toujours ça donc de toujours extrêmes
c'est clair que si on se met du point de
vue d'un animal vaut sans doute mieux
être élevée dans un
un petit élevage en plein air avec une
certaine attention qui est fait à
l'animal individus ne serait ce que
parce que il n'est pas perdue dans des
milliers d'autres individus là que
d'être exploités dans un dans une usine
dans une usine à viande donc ça c'est
oui c'est facile
mieux c'est sûr que c'est moins pire
mais c'est pas mais est ce que ça veut
dire que c'est acceptable c'est loin
d'être ce soit un pub du welfare isme
c'est ce qu'on peut appeler du wall
ferries droite cette idée que il faut
améliorer les conditions de vie des
animaux mais que globalement ça reste
acceptable de les exploiter en
particulier pour la pour l'alimentation
humaine donc les un argument puisque on
a juste que c'était l'utilitarisme
tantôt un argument utilitariste dans ce
cas-là été et de dire mais on quand
quand on est un animal dans des dans des
bonnes conditions on va quand même
abréger sa abréger sa vie c'est à dire
que malheureusement doute sur wells ça
dépend un peu d'espèces mais tout mais
en face on la logique y compris dans des
explications dans des exploitations dans
deux pattes en exploitation dans des
élevages soi-disant respectueux des
animaux puis qu'ils sont mieux que le
standard industriel
mais même dans ces dans ce type
d'élevage la logique ça reste une
logique de
productivité et donc on peut pas se
permettre de ne manger que des vieux
estimant qu'ils auraient d'écriture est
passé de melvin en oléron
il s'agit de l'est de les vendre et donc
on reste dans une logique d'exploitation
qui encore une fois si on se mettait
mais mettons qu'on transpose ça avec des
humains l'appui qu'on dit ouais on fait
des cds humains qui sont élevés dans des
bonnes conditions et tout ça puisque
l'os bien traiter ses s'appuya à quand
ils ont cinq ou six ans la pendant la
nuit sans leur faire de mal on est on
les euthanasie puis on les consomme on
dire non ça va pas c'est pas acceptable
on voit quelque chose de problématique
à la question aussi des pourquoi parce
que steam
aujourd'hui je crois que la plupart des
gens connaissent l'impact
environnemental exemple de manger de la
viande rouge août cédait pipi les enjeux
éthiques qui entoure ce ça c'est sans
connaître tous les tout en profondeur
mais je penserais pas des gens ont quand
même une idée pitt
j'écoutais un impôt qu'est ce que tu
avais fait puis donner une explication
c'est pourquoi les gens s'excitent pas
assez de juste avoir d'informations pour
faire un changement dans sa vie était un
exemple c'est des choix retient
aujourd'hui si tu fume la cigarette bien
au courant de ce que les effets négatifs
que ça sonne assez ça on a on a
l'impression que le cerveau humain on
lui dit un truc qui va comprendre il va
le faire mais non non ça marche pas du
tout ça va ça c'est mauvais pour soi
pour l'agrément pour plein de raisons
mais quand même compter de la fin pour
son intérêt personnel
non non on est pour son intérêt même à
présent pour son papa par habitude parce
que c'est difficile de changer
hier j'ai vu un chiffre qui était
hallucinant d'un livre qui récemment
sorti en france qui s'appelle sexisme et
l autriche part d'une étude suédoise ou
céder donc c'est des suédois qui sont
atteints des hommes suédois qui sont
atteints du cancer colorectal et puis
vont mourir de ce cancer là puis pour
vivre plus longtemps ou pour diminuer
peut-être leurs chances de
de mourir les médecins leur conseille de
leurs conseils leurs disent il faut
arrêter de manger de la viande on a
c'est vraiment pas bon pour ce que pour
ce que tu as comme cancer mais il ya eu
25 % de ces personnes armées qui
continue c'est tellement tellement fort
et alors lorsque ce que ce que ce que
dit loterie c'est que c'est aussi lié à
des enjeux de virilité aussi ouais ça
c'est un seul point qui m'a échappé un
peu en cause sur lequel je voulais c'est
la masculin la viande c'est valoriser
parce que c'est au départ un truc de
riches mais c'est aussi valoriser parce
que c'est parce que c'est masculin et
comme on est dans des sociétés où les
tweets masculins sont souvent plus
valorisé que les yeux que féminin ça
fait partie de
de halo du halo de bien autour de cette
scientifique certaines personnes peuvent
pas à peuvent pas qu'à arrêter quoi
c'est le meilleur coup marketing de
l'histoire de ce que ce coup là de faire
croire que le stake la viande s'était
fait fort c'est le meilleur coup
marketing sur le web puis mais l'idée
maintenant parce que tu disais la
cigarette la cigarette je peux je peux
comprendre je peux je peux comprendre
l'idée de vouloir continuer parce que là
la seule personne que tu as sur lequel
tu n es pas que si tu fais pas
l'intérieur avec des enfants maintenant
ils vont foncer sur la fumée secondaire
c'est sur thouet fait gayton l'idée de
fumée de travail c'est moi le pire
puis je moi je prends la décision de
continuer mais avec la viande mousse ce
que je vois sur taobao évidemment
évidemment le lien direct on parle
tantôt par rapport à l'éthique animale
si c'est directement tu manges tu manges
un individu que le droit de vivre le
team et en commun sur deux côtés ce qui
est déjà une grosse d'avoir à faire que
de médecins côté de continuer à
encourager l'industrie de la viande
c'est pas une décision qui ne tint pas
que toi tu une décision qui largement
impact la planète avec l'argument
environnemental ou et 3 6 0 et n'ont
cessé ces deux affaires différentes mois
s'est encore montré que quelqu'un qui
fume que je vois que féminin rouge vais
pas dire à toi ton raisonnement il pense
à plancher la série fais ce que tu veux
rien d'immoral cessa exact c'est
peut-être quelque chose de pas prudent
ouais pour sa santé mais avait rien de
dit moral encore une fois comme tu dis
si s'il n'y a pas de fumée secondaire
mais effectivement dans le cas de
consommer des produits animaux
alors il pourrait y avoir des preuves
des enjeux sur sa 106e netex mais c'est
exactement il ya aussi des enjeux sur
les individus que tu manges vue et puis
sur les conséquences effectivement
environnementales tout le monde toutes
les autres mais admettons que tout en
admettant que le spécisme puis que pour
toi les espèces qui sont pas humaine
sont inférieurs ouais quand même un
impact sur l'espèce humain c'est ça tu
tu fais du mal at on à ta propre espèce
assez les cds arguments qu'on peut
appeler anthropocentriste pour arrêter
de consommer de la viande dr et des
arguments de santé
aujourd'hui tu as les arguments liés aux
homos c'est à dire aux maladies ils
viennent d avantage d exploitation à la
commune a commis c'est pas très mais les
grippes aviaires des grippes porcines on
va on va en avoir d'autres des des
pandémies probablement et plus il y aura
d'exploitation animal plus on a de
chances qu'ils ans qui en est donc ça
c'est un argument santé au niveau de
l'emploi ces jours ci à la mode ces
arguments il serait bon et on se serait
monde le martelait ouais mais ça
n'empêche pas que les autres sont encore
valides au niveau environnement il faut
moi j'aime bien faire une distinction
souvent mais on mélange un peu
l'argument environnemental il ya tout
comme deux sous arguments il y en a un
qui l'argument climatique en tant que
tel à savoir l'impact géant en gaz à
effet de serre de
des produits animaux puis on sait que
c'est au tour de 14.5 sens là selon des
chiffres en sait assez conservateur mais
probablement assez vrai mais c'est assez
d'âgés beaucoup puisque les plus que les
trains c'est ça les transports on serait
plus autour de 12 13%
mais il ya aussi un argument inquiet pas
exactement le même que l'impact sur la
biodiversité
parce que comment vous savez sans doute
il ya une chute de la biodiversité très
très importante depuis je pense depuis
des 50 60 dernières années il ya comme
la moitié des animaux sauvages des
individus animaux sauvages qui rend
moins on est alors ça d'où ça vient ça
vient beaucoup du fait qu' on comprend
le territoire des animaux sauvages en
rang en amérique du sud où il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de biodiversité dans
la forêt amazonienne etc on rase de la
forêt pour faire pousser de la
nourriture pour le bétail destiné aux
humains
donc le fait indirectement le fait de
consommer des animaux encourage cette
participent à cette perte de
biodiversité c'est il ya deux arguments
environnementaux sur la biodiversité
puis 1 sur le réchauffement climatique
en tant que tel quand même je suis
évidemment je fais gagnent depuis trois
ans et demi puantes c'est pour la vie
puis j'ai j'accepte ces choses là mais
je pense que de plus en plus les gens si
sensibilise au moins sait déjà
non c'est sûr qu'il ya de plus en plus
de
vega n'y en a surtout chez les jeunes
c'est ça qui est encourageant là il
s'agit pas forcément que les personnes
âgées qui ont mangé de lorient toute la
vie toute leur vie change mais quelqu'un
qui va avoir une diète toute sa vie s'il
peut devenir vegan à ces jeunes c'est
bon c'est bon c'est ça c'est bon pour
tout le monde en fait c'est un peu
bizarre à dire mais n'importe qui
devrait désir pour des raisons
environnementales n'importe qui même
même qu'ils mangent de la viande du foie
gras etc qui se fout des enjeux des tic
animale devrait souhaiter que tout le
monde sauf lui deviennent pour des
raisons environnementales il ya un ça
devrait être ça le truc rationnaires
alors c'est pas c'est un peu quand même
c'est pas fou c'est quand même médecin
qui dirait ben moi je fumais vous
devriez pas fumer c'est pas c'est pas
dans votre votre intérêt donc c'est tout
tout tout vos auditeurs vos auditrice
même s'ils sont pas vegas il devrait
être actuellement le soin devrait
espérer que les autres le soin puis
manger en cachette éventuellement leur
leur berghuis cucs parce qu'on pourrait
arriver un jour à le monde bascule par
exemple les animaux raid et des droits
fondamentaux au ray serait protégé d'une
façon qui fait qu'on pourrait poli il
avoir comme des propriétés comprennent
pas les exploiter excuse est ce que
c'est quelque chose que si on regarde
mes temps l'évolution de peut-être de
d'autres courants 2,2 de droit à noter
que ce soit que ce soit les différentes
et la lutte contre le racisme
en plus comme l'esclavagé ce est ce que
est ce qui provoque cette même
révolution le chez les animaux à un
point où est-ce que l'exploitation et
animale soit complètement
je pense qu'on pourrait avoir un monde
vegan alors pas pas demain ni après
demain mais que ses seins
un horizon politique c'est une question
politique c'est une honte mais c'est
aussi politique c'est un horizon
politique qui on peut chercher à
atteindre quand tu disais si on se
compare avec d'autres si on compare avec
d'autres causes il ya quand même eu des
prochains mois c'est un progrès moral
clairement il ya eu des progrès moraux
important dans l'histoire de l'humanité
et donc voilà on évoquer le l'esclavagé
cela le fait que l'esclavagé est encore
malheureusement des esclaves en tout cas
c'est illégal donc le la fin de
l'esclavagé c'est un vrai progrès moral
l'égalité hommes femmes c'est un vrai
progrès moral l'égalité entre les mets
personne hétéro et courir non hétéro
entre les personnes valides et puis non
valide donc moi je le vois comme un
comme un espoir sans savoir quand ça
quand ça va arriver mais je suis plutôt
ça fait ça fait une bonne dizaine
d'années que je m'intéresse à ça et
c'est plutôt c'est quand même plutôt
encourageant en général les changements
vont plutôt dans le
bon sens même si au niveau mondial la
quantité d'animaux tués chaque année
quand même plutôt tendance à augmenter
alors c'est les consoles la consommation
et star est assez stable au canada
amérique du nord mais il ya d'autres
pays qui deviennent riches et qui
veulent se comporter comme les comme le
canada comme l'amérique du nord qui en
consomment beaucoup ça ça varie selon
les espèces
un truc qui me donne de l'espoir
ça pourrait être le développement de la
viande de culture donc sachez pas si
vous en avait déjà parlé
non c'est de la viande fait en labo
c'est ça c'est un peu le principe comme
[Musique]
une personne brûlée l'on peut on peut on
peut faire pousser sa peau dans des
boîtes d'oeufs
de pétri puis après lui il lui greffer
donc le principe que les cellules de
dechert sont capables de se reproduire
ça on le connaît depuis un certain temps
et là depuis quelques années il ya
beaucoup d'entreprises qui essaye
d'appliquer sa pour fabriquer de la
viande de qu'on appelle de la viande de
culture le premier premier burger
c'était je pensais en 2013 par un
néerlandais adrie coûter très très cher
là parce que ça fait ça avait pris 10
avait été fait un labo et mai
là c'est plus est plus tout à fait le
cas à singapour il ya un restaurant qui
qui a ça sur son séant sur son menu
c'est du poulet donc leur parle pas du
tout d'aider des viandes à base de soya
confesse il s'est tassé de la laf c'est
de la viande
free vient de la vraie viande mais sans
animal parce qu'il n'ya pas de ça
appartient pas être possible à ça comme
ça ça pousse dans des bars en a
semble-t-il ça ressemble un peu à des
cuves de bière le truc dans lequel on
est qu'ils aient poussé parce que moi ce
c'est sûr que j'en consomme pour propos
mais du point de vue du point de vue
hors casas et vegan c'est son examen de
vue moral n'y a pas d'exode ya pas de
souffrance associée moi c'est sûr que
j'en prends évidemment ma consommation
théorisé coûter cher au début puis c'est
sûr que je vais jamais retourné à manger
trois fois de la viande par jour ou
l'autre mais pour un barbecue ou le
dimanche jour si ça existe c'est sûr que
je les fais puis est ce que tu crois que
les que ça va être énormément difficile
parce que c'est la technologie existe x
ça pourrait être déployée massivement
éventuellement dans les prochaine années
maintenant c'est impossible de gens qui
investissent là dedans j'imagine aussi
voir beaucoup de gens qui vont investir
compte sur des résistances les lobbys de
deux des producteurs de toutes ces
choses là j'imagine que boire énormément
de résistance à cette idée là qu'on
puisse en laboratoire remplacer toute
leur business
ouais mais ça va ça va pas être facile
quand même parce que si le produit est
identique ou quasiment identique au
niveau goût qu'il est à peu près au même
prix et que la seule différence est que
dans un cas il ya un animal qui a été
tué sa tante ou changer bonne chance
pour faire le marketing
ils vont ils vont essayer de dire ah non
c'est pas de la même chose et tout mais
c'est pas sûr l'appui après on peut même
imaginer des dg un article qui parlait d
imaginer des mix devient on pourrait
faire de la de la viande qu'ils soient
moitié du ton et puis à moitié du cheval
ou jeudi même la viande humaine sur le
pas le principe est on peut l'appliquer
à tous on peut repérer l'affairé reste
au cij à notre époque hannibal
m'inquiète moi pas tu peux venir manger
ici puis on mange de la viande humaine
m'étais pas cannibale janvier
l'institution de l'éthique puis on
dirait que quand convoquant composent ce
cas qu'on dit c'est qu'on pourrait
manger dans un steak d'humains même fait
en laboratoire et comme quelque chose
qui vienne claque montrer que j'ai un
petit problème avec ça quand même
mais puisque pourtant c'est pas logique
parce qu'il ya mais du point de vue si
ça c'est comme les laiteries de tantôt
la moins du point de vue qu'ils y
arrivent du calcul bah tu vois qu'il ya
pas de ça fait de tort à personne
donc ta partie rationnelle utilitariste
dans ton cerveau dit let's go mais
probablement que
une partie plus émotionnelle te dis non
non en écoutant c'est inacceptable et
est donc réagir et u15 de biceps
si tu savais de ph good reads une longue
et un labo mangerait un bon steak débit
hsip sur le barbecue et je pense
faudrait que j'essaie de déprogrammer
mon cerveau ne convainc absolument
aucune
rien d'immoral la tabaski et personnes
que je sais je des cellules c'est ça
c'est sûr que c'est quelque part c'est
un bon c'est un gros choc est ce qu'on
est con et cette idée que c'est mal de
manger des jumeaux mais a dans des
circonstances particulières comme ça où
on est bien informé que il n'ya aucune
souffrance en animal en jeu ouais ya je
pense pas qu'ils aient d'objection
d'objection moral je savais pas qu'on
était si proche en fait je savais pas
que ça j'avais entendu parler qu'on
essayait de percer mais je savais pas
que ceux qui avaient déjà des gens qui
n'avaient manger c'est quelque chose qui
rompt plus on peut imaginer que dans les
prochaine à niveau doyen décennies c'est
une histoire d'année ah ouais ouais
après ce que ça va est-ce que ça va à
côté les des questions de coûts de
production pour pour que ça soit
révolutionnaire il faut que ce soit sont
même pris à peu près au même prix ça
pourrait être un tout petit peu plus
cher là mais tandis que ce soit à peu
près au même prix
et bon voilà ça ça suppose là que
l'industrie l'industrie se développe un
argument aussi puis ça c'est pas si
clair que ça c'est l'impact
environnemental non avenu sur le point
de vue un animal c'est clair que c'est
100% mieux du point de vue
environnemental
ça dépend quelle quantité d'énergie
nécessaire à faire pousser un kilo de
viande de culture versus un kilo de
viande est ce qu est ce qu on le sait à
cette étape-ci non parce qu'il n'y a pas
assez d à cette étape-ci ça ça reste des
trop petites productions et puis c'est
pas ma seule instance les sérums pour le
séance est encore un peu en
développement dont il ya encore de la
recherche
il ya encore la recherche à faire en
revanche ce dont on se comprend on peut
dire d'ores et déjà qui est sûr et puis
qu'est un bénéfice environnemental c'est
que ça prend beaucoup moins de bessat
prend quasiment zéro espace froid parce
que si si tu es bon si tu veux manger de
la viande de deux boeufs
mais il faut minimalement compter
l'espace qui a été nécessaire pour
produire la nourriture du boeuf et en
fait j'ai pas les chiffres en tête mais
la majorité des terres agricoles 22%
aujourd'hui sont utilisées pour de la
nourriture pour faire la nourriture pour
les animaux donc là avec de la viande de
culture on n'a pas ça et du coup ça veut
dire que les places où on aurait fait
pousser du soja mais tomba là on peut on
peut laisser la biodiversité reprendre
ses droits la forêt les arbres dont ça
se serait par la gestion la gestion de
l'espace minimalement déjà un bon coup
du point de vue environnemental
reste à savoir
le niveau d'émissions de ges si c'est
pareil si c'est mieux ce site asie tu
sais si les gens qui nous écoutent c'est
désormais je vais attendre que ça arrive
sur les tablettes avant de faire le saut
brûlées gardent au problème en proto
longtemps les deux aimants aussi le goût
de la viande des mouches végétarien je
pouvais gagner le goût de la vie
aquatique et le goût de la viande quand
même quelque chose qui a amené à après
certains moments nous dérange plus parce
que pour moi je dis je me lève pas le
matin en ayant cru rêver de big n fils
quand je vois un steak sommes dérange
pas je dis j'ai pu peut-être je pense qu
au début comme n'importe quel sevrage
n'importe quoi il ya cette période là
que ça me paraît difficile après un
certain temps mais c'est même plus
difficile vu quelque chose que j'ai
envie je laisserai la viande de
laboratoire peut-être que si je commence
à en manger je retrouverai ce goulot
mais aussi été jugée j'ai
personnellement mais j'imagine pour la
bourre beaucoup de dégâts mais je ne
vais jeter rien celle que je suis plus
nécessaire si je penserai je serai moins
enthousiaste que ph à vouloir manger des
baskets parce que moi ce que tu dis là
ça me rejoint pas du tout ah non non moi
je moi je marche d'un rucher un barbecue
mais attends je vais encore et encore ça
me donne encore envie mais c'est pas
quand tu parles une nécessité c'est pas
une nécessité facilement capable de
juste passer à travers mais ça sent bon
ben ali ce coin jean le bihan de mythes
la com
ce dont je me souviens de la vraie
affaire moi ce qui est vrai ce qui me
manquerait plus ça serait les fromages
alors toi t'as pas loin de parler donc
ph
excusez moi ça a été facile comme ça je
suis pas passé par goethe à rien mais
aucun mérite
maintenant moi j'ai un api de couverts
et même le pays du fromage l'a donc
j'avoue que ça c'était le plus le plus
difficile après aujourd'hui il ya des
fromages de noir qu'ils ont quand même
assez qui commence à être intéressant
mais avec ce principe de faire pousser
des cellules deviennent on peut aussi le
faire avec des séries mais oui c'est ça
de l'est donc on pourrait imaginer des
fromages devrait les pour le futur donc
mais mme hama donc ouais moi aussi comme
comme ph dans le temps en temps je sens
l'odeur du barbecue ça peut me faire ça
peut me faire saliver mais globalement
ça fait maintenant plus de dix ans que
je suis mégane
j'ai quand même l'impression que matt cc
reste purement dans le truck plaisir-là
gustatif que je mange mieux qu'avant je
suis sûr que ma palette est plus
diversifiée un peu parce que aussi voilà
quand tu te tais tu grandis tu es
habitué à manger un peu tout le temps
les mêmes choses puisque son manche est
où huit animaux différents là et puis
plein de plein de fromage mais quand tu
enlèves ça de ton
de ton assiette bah oui tu as un moment
donné tu veux tu vas aller chercher des
nouvelles des nouvelles saveurs et ouais
je mange mais ma blonde et très très
bonne aussi pour pour cuisiner puis on
se cuisinent des choses le dimanche pour
tout là pour toute la semaine
moi aussi je suis un peu diversifiés que
j'étais avant garde définitivement puis
comment est-ce que
tu passes de l'éthique animale pour
s'intéresser à l'intelligence
artificielle qui pour poser des
questions éthiques dans un autre domaine
complètement
il ya un peu le hasard des circonstances
à savoir que c'était en 2017 il y avait
une offre d'emploi à l'université de
montréal pour un poste de chercheur en
éthique de l'intelligence artificielle
et puis des données massives
alors pourquoi cette offre d'emploi a eu
lieu notamment parce que au québec qu'on
a un chercheur en intelligence
officielle qui s'appelle lieu je suis à
bengio qui est à un des chercheurs les
plus célèbres dans le domaine à
beaucourt savoir dessiner mais qui est
très occupé ouais effectivement
et donc quand le gouvernement québec
canada ont vu qu'on avait ce potentiel
ils ont injecté delà de l'argent et puis
il ya une partie de cet argent qui est
qu'ils allaient aux enjeux des tic et
donc moi c'est là donc que je suis
rentré après d'un point de vue plus +
philo si on veut le point le point
commun entre eux
l'éthique animale et puis les tics de
l'intelligence artificielle c'est que
ces deux éthique non humaine pendant ton
centre s'intéresse dans un cas aux
animaux dans l'autre ou en robots mais
arrête de l'éthique temps de parler un
petit peu plus tôt justement ces deux de
très rapidement quitter l'île les
machines je dirais éventuellement en
développement développant cette
intelligence artificielle le finissent
par développer dans un type de
essentielle finalement puis en ce moment
là les mêmes questions reviennent les
mains les questions qu'on se pose est ce
trop d'espoir les animaux revient
prémâché tout à fait mon à l'expérience
de l'éthique animale qu'on peut
appliquer à l'éthique et l'éthique des
robots et moi une bonne c'est en éthique
une bonne façon de faire là ces deux
courses et de comparer un peu des
domaines aussi j'ai des bonnes raisons
de penser que c'est mal de torturer un
animal
qui ressent la douleur je devrais avoir
des intuitions semblables face à un
robot qui ressent la douleur
torturé heureusement pour les robots ils
ressentent pas la douleur encore
actuellement pas encore mais c'est ça
peut-être qu'il faut il faut éviter
pourrait demander à yoshi à bendjé ou ne
surtout pas développé de conscience
artificielle mais aussi les robots les
machines les trois officielles on en
voit de plus en plus de décisions et
cyclo ou même apprendre fait ça c'est
tout un c'est ça quand on quand on parle
des robots qu'on ne l'a qui on devrait
pas faire mal c'est on parle des robots
en tant que patient moreau mais là ta
question c'est parler des robots en tant
que agents eux-mêmes ce qu'on peut
appeler des agents moreau artificielle
qui en fait le le livre que j'ai publié
l'an dernier qui s'appelle faire la
morale aux robots c'est exactement ça
son sujet c'est comment
programmé des agents au morro
artificielle vers l'exemple que j'aime
bien donner c'est les voitures autonomes
parce que les voitures autonomes bon si
on prend une voiture non autonome avec
un animal humain qui qui conduit qu'on
imagine alors c'est un peu un dilemme du
tramway un peu comme tantôt là mais
imaginons un enfant et un vieillard
donc si c'est un humain qui est un an il
va se passer un accident si si tourner à
gauche et tu l'enfance il tourne à
droite tu le verras si c'est un humain
qui conduit trop bas et que ça se passe
vite il aura juste pas le temps de
réfléchir puis ça va être réflexe ce qui
se passe si on a une voiture autonome
c'est que on peut anticiper les choses
et même en tête face on a le devoir
d'anticiper les choses et de poser la
question qui est si la de notre voiture
autonome elle se retrouve dans une
situation comme ça écraser un enfant ou
un vieillard c'est quoi la caisse
qu'elle devrait faire quelle est la
bonne quelle est la bonne à la bonne
chose à faire du point de vue
donc là on a un bon exemple une
technologie les voitures autonomes nous
force à à établir des codes avec la
viande et nouveau code à être
comme dit je pense et l'oncle de
superman de spider man plus de plus de
responsabilités plus de pouvoir juste
plus voir en plus de responsables tous
de responsabilité mais on est on est
dans une situation que cet ordre là on
crée des encres et des robots et donc on
augmente le pouvoir humain mais comme
ces robots peuvent avoir des
conséquences sur d'autres humains on a
une responsabilité les programmeurs les
programmes heuzé ont une responsabilité
on y pense ça me force à se poser les
questions philosophiques qu'on n'aurait
pas été porté à poser au moment des
moments de coder la machine moment de
donner son livre d'instruction faveur
des jeux attend qu humain répondu à ses
questions ses soeurs dans ces projets se
poser les questions c'est d'arriver avec
une réponse
on a passé beaucoup d'enjeu éthiques on
n'arrive pas une réponse claire
d'avancer on arrive à des suppositions
mais là la l'ingénieur l'ingénieur qui
fabrique la voiture il veut sa voix
rauque et en cas de qu'est ce que je
fais moi si la voiture est capable
d'identifier il ya un enfant guillard
est ce que on restreint d'homme ou est
ce qu on applique un certain nombre de
principes et des est donc cet exemple là
je le développe dans le livre on peut
retrouver nos théories morale parce que
les en fait il ya c'est une question
très concrète qui avaient été posées par
le ministère des transports allemand un
comité est alarmant donc et c'est sur
quels principes on n'utilise pour
programmer les voitures autonomes
autonome est ce qu'il ya des choses plus
morale que d'autres et donc ce qu avait
répondu le comité entre autres choses
c'est on devrait pas faire de
discrimination selon les personnes donc
en l'occurrence enfants vieillards
il devrait pas y avoir de discrimination
selon l'âge
donc ya pas de bonne réponse donc ce
qu'on pourrait si on veut traduire ça en
algorithmes en programmation pour dire
il faut tirer la voiture devrait tirer
au sort quoi si les enfants ne doit pas
prendre de décision donc ça c'est et ça
c'est un raisonnement plutôt
déontologiques qui s'appuie sur l'idée
c'est mal de discriminer selon de la
jamais temps mais en fait quand on
demande aux gens pillent tout le monde
peut à peut être aussi cette intuition
on on dit ouais quand même
il ya l'enfant il pourrait y avoir un
côté pour sauver et sauver l'enfant
parce que hélas c'est plutôt une
intuition et illzach east il lui reste
plus d'années à vivre en moyenne et donc
si l'idée c'est de produire du bonheur
dans l'univers bien souvent l'enfant
probablement qu'on peut espérer produire
plus de bonheur que deux camps souvent
le camp souvent le vieillard
donc là on a vraiment une opposition
entre les deux
durée mois les pires on sait pas comment
faire ardent dans le livre moi je
propose une une une alternative qui a
encore une troisième théorie que j'ai
pas encore évoqué jusqu'à présent ils
s'appellent l'éthique de la vertu alors
pour présenter les tics de la vertu on
pourrait dire donc là comme disais
tantôt la morale c'est répondre à la
question quelle est la bonne chose à
faire et c'est un peut répondre à cette
question c'est intéressant en
conséquence donc ça c'est l'utilitarisme
avoir les meilleurs conséquences
possibles on peut s'intéresser à cette
question en se demandant quelle est la
bonne action ce qu'il ya des actions qui
sont autorisés ce qui est des actions
qui sont interdites et là on est plutôt
dans la logique déontologique mais on
peut aussi s'intéresser à cette question
du point de vue de l'agent de la
personne qui agit et se demander est ce
que la personne qui agit elle est une
bonne ou une mauvaise personne par
exemple et ça c'est c'est un peu l'idée
qu'il ya derrière les tic delà de la
vertu de considérer le paysage morale à
partir des des agents n'ont pas de
l'action de ses conséquences est alors
prêt techniquement quelle est la réponse
de l'éthique de la vertu à la question
quelle est la bonne chose à faire ce
qu'ils vont répondre cessé de faire ce
que ferait une bonne personne
une personne vertueuse dans des
circonstances similaires dans des
circonstances analogues donc je parle de
typiquement mettons socrates
qu'est ce que ferait socrates qu'est ce
que ferait jésus ou qui vous voulez que
vous estimez être une personne ça dépend
aussi comment définit la vertu mais
typiquement ça va être des choses comme
être généreux juste ce palier à la
sexualité c'est c'est
générosité justice on était des choses
comme ça et donc mon l'idée que je
présente dans le livre c'est de
d'essayer d'appliquer cette théorie de
la vertu or beaucoup faire entre
guillemets des robots fabriquer des
robots vertueux ça c'est la preuve que
tu connais le que tu bois un mois
exactement hockey parce que ça reste on
faisait pas aléatoire mais ça reste un
peu par arbitrage à trouver le bon mot
mais de dire que ces idéaux leur convoi
que bertin comme comme vertueux il doit
bien avoir des critères à partir
desquels étudiants fait les deux ne les
a nommés mais je m'achète secteur leçons
sont pas nécessairement absolue ils
peuvent ils peuvent être dépendamment du
contexte dépendamment de l'époque où
dépendamment de toutes sortes de ça peut
ça peut changer ce qui perturbe une
époque où c'est dans une certaines
civilisations pl pour ne pas là dans une
autre peut-être ça ouais ça saigne à une
question difficile en éthique c'est un
peu là c'est la question de s qui a des
principes moraux universels ou parce que
tout est absolument
c'est techniquement même c'est ce qu'on
appelle une question de meetic qui est
la branche de l'éthique qui
s'intéressent à ce genre de questions ce
qu'on peut dire c'est qu'il ya quand
même certaines certaines choses qui
semblent vraiment mal on évoqué l'
esclavage bon c'est pas parce que dans
la grèce antique même aristote le
philosophe trouvé que c'était ben
correct esclavage que ça l'était donc
oui si on avait fait un sondage dans la
grèce antique ou dans le les états unis
du sud esclavagiste au 19e siècle
plupart des gens c'est tout à fait
acceptable pour pour faire un calcul
utilitariste c'est mettons aussi ce
sujet
mettons que j'ai dix esclaves dans le
monde puisse y avec ses dix-sept clubs
le tout le reste des bêtes des gens
virés bien une vie parfaite utilitariste
de débat en europe choix de ça c'est une
critique et qui peut être fait à
l'utilitarisme de dire en fait
l'utilitarisme on peut imaginer des
situations où ça apporte des situations
qui sont un peu contre contre intuitif
pour deux pour donner un exemple
que j'aime bien c'est on pourrait
justifier le fait de faire que des
chrétiens se fasse manger par des lions
dans les arènes romaines
s'il ya quelques chrétiens et puis il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de spectateurs qui ont
un grand plaisir à voir les chrétiens se
faire manger par les lions la halle
utilitariste istréens il est un peu
ennuyés parce qu'il est un peu obligé
dira si ça si effectivement alors il ya
des il ya des stratégies pour cent pour
s'en sortir en particulier peut garder
ce rappel utile vérisme négatif qui dit
non ce qu'il faut c'est pas maximiser le
bien-être c'est minimiser le matin c'est
ce bilan peut minimiser c'est une
minimiser le mal être des chrétiens peu
importe le plaisir qu'en tire lait les
spectateurs mais en tout cas il y à ce
type de défi il ya aussi un argument
contre l'utilitarisme qui est ce qu'on
appelle le monstre d'utilité donc faut
imaginer une personne qui est très très
bizarre mais quand on lui donne mettons
à aucun quand elle peut torturer des
humains quand elle mange des des humains
ça lui procure beaucoup beaucoup plus de
bonheur que l icom en extase totale
quand elle torture des gens et puis on
calcule que c'est plus fort que le
malheur des gens qu'ils à l'utilitarisme
obligé dire dans ce cas là c'est correct
de lui devenait du monde à torturer bon
encore une fois il peut y avoir des
stratégies pour pour répondre à ça mais
en deux en dehors de ses cales
d'utilitarisme et est quand même une
bonne
une théorie moral en tout cas qui peut
qui peut nous amener apprennent à
prendre des décisions raisonnables dans
de nombreux dans de nombreuses
situations les brèves d'un code des
algorithmes tant que d'intelligence
artificielle je préconiserais plutôt de
programmer une machine pour qu'elle
agisse comme certains modèles de
personnes qu'on juge virtuel exactement
ouais ouais parce que y'a des il ya des
il ya des difficultés inhérentes aux
robots utilitariste roubaud
déontologique notion si on pense aux
robots déontologique là qu'on se demande
comment est ce qu'on devrait le
programme est en gros il faut lui donner
des règles et puis en fait il ya il ya
plein de règles morales donc il faut non
seulement lui donner des règles il faut
lui dire qu'aussi comment les
hiérarchise c'est un peu si vous n'avez
pas entendu parler de deux lois de la
robotique des a quasiment vu un écrivain
de science fiction c'est un peu ça qui
fait c'est y donne trois grandes règles
et puis disent et c'est comme ça qu'il
faut programmer les robots alors quid
alors de mémoire la première règle c'est
de ne pas faire de mal un humain la
deuxième règle c'est de toujours obéir
aux humains et la troisième c'est de se
préserver de passe se tuer mais voilà on
voit bien jusque là la première règle ne
pas faire mal à un humain ça nous ça
nous permet pas de décider si on doit
sacrifier l'enfant le l'égard de masse
est assez insuffisant
et donc voilà si on voulait fou si on
voulait avoir un robot utilitariste
apparemment un robot d anthologiste il
faut complètement prêt à être jetés dans
le monde là il faut il faut il faudrait
que toutes les règles morales en fait on
l'est on les connaît c'est puis qu on
les élit rares cheese et puis ce n'est
pas le cas dans arma ii grand livre des
règles morales on l'a dans certains dans
certains cas puis la l'économie de
charges de base voyons voir pour et
c'est sûr on pourrait s'appuyer sur les
chars des des droits humains des droits
des droits français renvoient toutes les
castes mais ça répond pas à toutes les
questions sauf pas toutes les situations
et et comment les hiérarchiser et c'est
donc il ya des limites aux robots
déontologique l'euro le robot
utilitariste lui il va avoir des donc
lui en gros il va agir de façon à
maximiser le bien
de tous les êtres sensibles qui sont
impliqués par son action alors là il
peut y avoir des difficultés parce que
en gros le robot utilise à pipe
ça correspond peut-être on peut parler
un tout petit peu de dia pour faire le
pour faire le d'intelligence
artificielle pour faire le lien
parce qu'il ya différentes techniques en
intelligence artificielle musée ça ça
commence à être un vieux domaine on
entend beaucoup parler en ce moment mais
ça existe depuis au moins les années
1950 et les premiers types
d'intelligence artificielle qui ont bien
marché genre les machines qui sont
capables de battre des humains aux
échecs et la vie elle l'a dépassée mais
sur un truc bien précis là les allées et
chemins qui s'appelait des blues était
deep blue qui avait battu je pense le
champion garry kasparov et donc ça
c'était une intelligence artificielle
qui fonctionnait un peu avec derek comme
ça qui est aussi une grande puissance de
calcul qu'ils étaient capables
d'envisager plein plein de coups
d'avancé davantage que le cerveau humain
donc avec les un peu de la force brute
comme ça ils arrivaient à battre
des champions d'échecs ça il faut ça
c'était un type d'intelligence
artificielle qui était on dit un peu
programmé à la main écrit à la main
c'est à dire que c'était des règles et
puis on donnait toutes les règles ou à
la machine ce qui est arrivé et puis
c'est de ça dont on comptait pour ça
qu'on parle beaucoup d'intelligence
artificielle c'est qu'on a une type de
technique maintenant qu'il est où
l'intelligence artificielle on l'a
programme pas à la main elle apprend
tout seul dont on parle d'apprentissage
automatique
là il ya deux au moins deux façons de
faire de l'apprentissage automatique une
première c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'apprentissage par renforcement un peu
comme un
un enfant ou un animal qu'on
quand il fait un truc bien on lui donne
une récompense quand il fait un truc mal
on lui donne pas de récompense
on peut faire un peu ça avec des avec
des machines et par exemple pour le
alors pour le jeu d'échecs
le jeu d'échecs sa rentrée dans la cage
et paddy le terme de ce qu'on appelle un
système expert qu'on oppose donc au
système avec apprentissage automatique
un truc comme alpha 0 qui a gagné une
partie de go contre le donc legault
c'est un jeu c'est un peu comme les
échecs chinois mais c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué en fait il ya beaucoup
beaucoup plus de possibilités puis les
bons joueurs de go ils sont quasiment
incapable d'expliquer c'est plus de
l'intuition
il voit le damier avec des pierres
blanches et puis des pierres noires et
puis ils sont pas forcément capable
d'expliquer mais ils ont une intuition
très très fort donc on part et puis du
point de vue purement mathématique le
nombre de coups possibles au go et
beaucoup beaucoup plus important que le
nombre de coups possibles aux échecs
si fait que les techniques avec des
systèmes d'experts et derek ça marchait
pas mais on s'est rendu compte qu'avec
l'apprentissage automatique et en
particulier l'apprentissage par
renforcement donc là en gros on a on a
fait jouer le système contre lui-même
plein plein plein plein de parties très
très très vite avec des grosses machines
et là la machine alpha go puis après
venu alpha 0 a appris à être super bonne
au bout il ya un documentaire sur
netflix qui s'appellera le fagot je
pense qu'ils racontent qu'ils racontent
l'histoire et c'est pour ça qu'on parle
ben c'est ça c'est une technique
relativement nouvelle qui marche très
bien
la trois et alors cette première la
première technique le les systèmes
experts c'est à ça il ya des affinités
avec l'éthique déontologique la
l'apprentissage par renforcement ou il
s'agit il ya un but à atteindre
il ya des affinités avec l'utilitarisme
le but atteint saidal et maximiser le
bien-être et il ya une troisième
catégorie 2
techniques d'intelligence artificielle
qui est l'apprentissage superviser donc
je suis à bendjo donc ont évoqué c'est
là dedans qu'il a c'est pas mal la norme
qu'il a fait des découvertes importantes
là l'idée de l'apprentissage superviser
c'est de donner des exemples à des
algorithmes et en leur donnant beaucoup
beaucoup d'exemples ils finissent par
apprendre à distinguer des choses par
exemple on leur donne des images de
chiens des images de chats et façon un
peu alors c'est pas magique mais il ya
quelque chose qu'on comptera pas
forcément la machine est capable d'
elle-même un moment donné on lui donne
ensuite une image de shakala jamais vu
et elle est capable d'identifier parce
qu'elle a compris les patterns de ce
deuxième dès qu'une image de deux chiens
ou de ou de chats et dont on parle
d'apprentissage supervisé qui fonctionne
par exemple on dort on donne des
exemples beaucoup beaucoup d'exemples et
en fait on peut faire le lien entre
cette technique d'intelligence
artificielle et puis là la troisième
théorie morale l'éthique de la vertu
parce qu'elle aussi elle fonctionne à
partir de l'exemple pour pour l'éthique
de la vertu la bonne chose à faire c'est
de suivre finalement l'exemple de ce que
ferait une personne vertueuse et donc
l'idée que je développe dans le livre
c'est ça c'est de faire se rencontrer
les tics de la vertu et puis
l'apprentissage superviser donc de d'une
certaine manière d'utiliser la la la
sagesse acquise par les humains au cours
des siècles en développant des vertus et
puis de faire que ça se soit à prix par
les par les machines
je pose une question en fait je veux
créer un scénario où on veut ajouter une
troisième option au dilemme du vieillard
depuis de l'enfant ou l'option c'est la
voiture et donc sont son passage et son
conducteur se sacrifie la personne
vertueuse probablement ce serait
l'option qui apprendrait sauf que
personne n'achèterait cette voiture
neuve qui se sacrifierait devant ce
dilemme le web ça dépend comment on pose
la question la personne vertueuse
peut-être pour si elle est bon spot pas
sûr que toutes les personnes vertueuses
sacrifierait mais c'est vrai qu'on a on
a quand même cette impression ça serait
ça si l'option si ce gpo choix de de
tuer ou de donner ma vie autre que dans
mon imaginaire d'une personne virtual
situations pression reprend le cas
tantôt de pousser la personne sur la
voie pourrait penser que la personne
vertueuse elle se sacrifierait puis elle
se jetterais sur la voie pour sauver les
les 5 donc on pourrait imaginer quelque
chose d'un peu analogue avec la la
voiture autonome mais encore une fois la
sq ont si l'idée c'est de faire que les
les voitures autonomes se comporte comme
se comporterait des personnes vertueuses
ça dépend un peu de ce qu'on demande à
la personne vertueuse on peut lui
demander qu'est ce que toi tu ferais
dans cette situation puis elle se
sacrifierait pas ça veut dire que l'on
programme les voitures pour que les
sacrifie les les passagers mais elle
pourrait aussi avoir une regard un peu
plus extérieur et puis se dire ok à ton
avis est ce que on devrait programmer
les voitures pour que sacrifie
systématiquement les occupants de la
voiture et là c'est pas si clair que les
personnes vertueuses ça resterait de
dépendre à la limite de quel est l'âge
de la personne dans la voiture
donc si là encore on pourrait sans doute
mais ce qui ce qui est probable c'est
que les personnes vertueuses aurait pas
toutes la même intuition en fait on en
aurait même si on reste à deux options
là qu'on en aurait qui pensent que il
faut sauver l'enfant donc qu'il pense il
faut sauver le vieillard d'autres qui
pensent qu'il faut tirer au sort et le
la solution que je propose elle consiste
un peu à utiliser ça c'est à dire faire
un tirage au sort en pondérant si on
sait mettons que 30% des personnes
vertueuses pense qu'il faut sauf à ce
qu'il vaut mieux tirés au sort que 20%
pensent qu'il faut sauver le vieillard
et que 50 % pensent qu'il faut sauver
l'enfant mais la voiture programmée
selon ce modèle éthique de la vertu mais
face au dilemme elle tire lll tirés au
sort dans 50 % d'escale sauvé l'enfant
dans 20% la soirée le vieillard et dans
30 cents elle ferait un deuxième tirage
au sort dans cette phase est une façon
de dire ouais y'a il est possible
d'envisager un modèle de robot qui d'une
certaine façon elite l'ailé
et la société l'a pas toute la société
les personnes vertueuses
parce que justement c'est ça on veut pas
que si on fait un robot si on veut faire
un robot moral on veut qu'il soit mieux
que le l'humain au moyen oient tant qu'à
faire
donc le leur donc l'idée c'est donc de
le faire s'inspirer par des modèles les
plus les meilleurs les meilleures
possibles mais la difficulté c'est en
entendant tant qu'humain sur son site il
est menacé ouais mais est ce que c'est
si c'est si difficile que ça moi je suis
pas certain
c'est souvent dans la réaction que les
gens font ok mais comment on va décider
qui sont les personnes vertueuses
mais ça me semble alors c'est pas un
problème que je résous vraiment dans le
dans le livre mais dix mois mon
intuition c'est que peut-être
l'intelligence collective qu'on appelle
l'intelligence des foules l'ancien
demande un peu à tout le monde qu'on dit
bombay désigné mois autour des personnes
que vous connaissez vraiment il s'agit
pas de voter pour leurs animateurs quand
je pense aux personnes version de
l'iphone
peut-être parce que moi et si et si t'es
pas complètement mélanger épices
techniquement et puis que unique toile
est effectivement un tout petit peu
mieux que la teneur moyenne par oovoo
clairement mieux que là que la moyenne
et puis qu'on a plein de vie que
d'autres personnes disent ouais ouais
nicole en fait il est vraiment honnête
et généreux et etc
mais ouais on va prendre nicole et puis
on c'est lui qu'on va évidemment parmi
d'autres personnes on utilise ces
données pour essayer de construire un
robot à l'image d'un groupe de personnes
vertueuses puis en temps en temps qui
est sien qui regardent l'intelligence
artificielle évoluer qu'ils sont les
ports ou les dangers que ça atteindre
parce qu'on dirait mettons moins de
regarder cela de l'extérieur de voir
l'intelligence artificielle de comment
ça se fait que cette balance et les
vidanges et par la science fiction par
exemple
je trouve que des fois ça va vite puis
des fois ça des fois ça l'art de
commencer à pas à prendre tout seul mais
de ça semble être une pente qui peut
être glissante qu'en tant qu'haïtien est
ce qu'il ya une peur c'est ce qui donne
une limite qu'on voit qu'il faut pas
franchir
qu'est-ce qui c'est parce que
l'apprentissage est le deuxième méthode
d'apprentissage que tu mentionnes
renforcement bas renforcement
ça m'apparaît comme quelque chose qui
est potentiellement infinis prix ouais
c'est ce qui peut devenir un peu touché
qu'un conte ya ce fameux on peut même
dans les dents ballon déjà tu as tu as
raison la la la l'image qu'on a des
vieillards des robots et des pas façonné
par la recherche scientifique est
façonnée par la filiation et puis là une
bonne fiction ça si c'est mieux aussi à
d s'il ya des méchants et puis yens des
robots mais chance et ça fait une bonne
fiction en réalité les chercheurs en
éthique de l'intelligence artificielle
qui sont pencher là dessus il ya un truc
qui est qui pourrait faire peur c'est
les super intelligent le philosophe qui
a développé ça s'appelle knicks bonic
bostrom il est si les suédois maintenant
il travaille il est à oxford
parce que si l'intelligence son idée la
suivante il intelligence mais il n'est
pas le seul mais il a remarqué que si
l'intelligence pour l'instant on a des
intelligences artificielles étroite donc
ils sont capables de gagner des humeurs
aux échecs gagner des humains ou de ses
services et il peut faire des bêtises
éventuellement dans ce champ là mais
mais mais pas plus
mais l'objectif de beaucoup de
chercheurs en ia c'est d'avoir son appel
d intelligence artificielle général donc
il sera un peu capable comme l'esprit
humain de passer d'un domaine à un autre
et puis de gagner au go mais aussi de
conduire une voiture mais aussi de
s'occuper des enfants ou je ne sais quoi
sauf que ce que ce que dit bostrom c'est
supposons qu'une un type qu'on arrive à
fabriquer des intelligences
artificielles général et non plus
étroite
il n'y a pas forcément de raison pour
que
dès l'instant que l'intelligence
artificielle à un peu compris comment
les choses fonctionnent et quelques elle
continue pas elle a progressé tout seul
dans son coin qu elle nous surpasse de
beaucoup est donc çà et là on obtient
une super intelligence et une super
intelligent ce bien là on peut avoir des
scénarios de super intelligence hostiles
à l'être humain parce que six métopes là
on extrapole beaucoup parce que je me
rappellerai mais j'avais le martyr qu'il
y avait deux orateurs qui commencèrent
communiquer entre eux puis qu'il y avait
juste tirer la plogue de sauvion avait
juste le temps qu'il se parler un
langage en fait que les que les humains
comprennent des potes comme si les deux
ordinateurs avaient développé a commencé
à se communiquer d'une manière qu'on
pouvait pas comprendre c'est tellement
un peu monté en épingle avait payé n'est
pas de vrai danger c'est pas exactement
c'était un peu une fausse alerte et on
était très très très loin des supers
intelligence mais c'est vrai qu' il peut
y avoir des choses qu'on comprend pas en
en particulier avec l'apprentissage
permise et quand il ya des plein plein
de couches qu'on appelle l'apprentissage
profond juste parfait juste profondément
parce que on peut facilement imaginer
même avec toutes les conventions
conclues tantôt sur le véganisme que
quiconque qu'un intelligent une super
intelligent ce qui commence à regarder
le monde autour commence à réaliser que
l'humain et pas nécessairement bon pour
le monde autour le séisme et au lavage
chine faisant un calcul utilitariste qui
disait l'humain cause tant de tort à
toutes les espèces animales ou à ou ados
d'humains on veut juste rayer les
meilleures épices et ce ne serait pas
forcément irrationnelles
maintenant ça serait vraiment c'est pas
si clair mais en tout cas pour nous eh
ouais pour nous en tant qu'espèce pour
le montrant qu'un individu ça dépend
mais pour tout pour revenir aux dangers
de la
la super donc là ce serait une super
intelligence utilitariste là qui aurait
fait le calcul général et puis qui se
rend compte que si on veut améliorer le
bien-être général de tous les êtres
sensibles
il ya peut-être une espèce qui est
nuisible mais si si on oublie ce
scénario et qu'on regarde plus
généralement le cette idée que tu disais
avec l'apprentissage par renforcement
qui pourrait comme aller trop loin donc
la nique bostrom il ay la une une
expérience de pensée qui est amusante
c'est l'expérience de pensée de la
machine à trombone la deûle à luzy d'un
trombone
supposons que on a une intelligence
artificielle et puis on lui donne comme
objectif de fabriquer des trombones
paperclip et appuyons lui du jce
il faut que tu fasses dès cette
admission dans la vie c'est de faire des
paperclip ben là on peut tout à fait
imaginer si on ne dit rien d'autre qu'
elle détruit l'humanité pour fabriquer
des
et des trombones parce que après tout
eux
il y aurait un risque par exemple que
l'être humain décide d'éteindre la
machine
donc pour éviter que l'humain est elle
la machine et pour vraiment réaliser son
objectif de faire des trombones éliminé
l'humanité pourrait être un objectif
secondaire rationnelle pertinents où il
pourrait y avoir elle a besoin du
maximum de matière pour faire le maximum
de trombone puis les humains sont faits
en carbone et on peut faire des
supposant qu'on peut transformer la
matière humaine en trombone
donc il serait rationnel pour la la la
machine qu'il suit son objectif
aveuglément de d'anéantir l'humanité
évidemment il y a des idées on peut
essayer d'éviter ça mais il ya toute une
tout un domaine de réflexion en éthique
de l'ia sur la sécurité des supers
intelligence comment faire puis c'est
quand même une vraie difficulté est là
parce que ce qu'il faut c'est arrivé
d'une certaine manière à tenir
à tenir en boîte quelque chose qui est
potentiellement beaucoup plus
intelligent que que l'être humain est
c'est pas c'est pas si simple que ça
alors avec moi mamam solution en tout
cas la solution qui peut dériver de
l'éthique de la vertu c'est de dire ce
qu'il faut c'est pas donner des
objectifs du genre fabrique des
trombones ou maximise le bien-être de
tous les êtres sensibles mais c'est fait
ce que ferait des personnes vertueuses
puis lancer les personnes vertueuses
elles vont pas éliminé l'humanité où
elles vont pas être utilitariste
orthodoxe à vouloir absolument maximiser
le
le bien-être mais c'est mais alors voila
tu me demandais les dangers il ya ça
après des dangers plus ça c'est quand
même du long terme et pas et pas sur la
mais des dangers plus plus concret moyen
terme
il ya les questions de remplacement du
de la main d'oeuvre parce qu'aussi si on
fait de l'intelligence artificielle
c'est pour qu'elle fasse des tâches qui
étaient en général qui était autrefois
fait par des humains donc là encore le
les voitures autonomes très un bon
exemple 6 assists la technologie soda se
répand ça veut dire que les gens qui
conduisent des voitures ou des camions
et dont c'est le métier ils vont devoir
changer de métier s'apprend c'est
clairement pas pour demain là on nous
promet tout temps la voiture autonome
pour l'année prochaine mais on en est
encore loin mais en tout cas les laits
toutes ces technologies là elles sont
faites pour pour remplacer donc il peut
y avoir un chômage induit ça c'est un un
vrai enjeu il ya les enjeux qui sont
liées à la surveillance aussi parce que
toute ces c'est cette intelligence
artificielle qui fonctionne par
apprentissage avec des exemples avec des
données c'est en fait c'est
indissociable l'intelligence
artificielle telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui est ce qu'on appelle le big
data le fait qu'il ya plein mais non de
données disponibles parce que les gens
cliquent et puis les les
les algorithmes se souviennent qu est-ce
que vous avez cliqué mais ça va vraiment
ensemble mais du coup ça va vraiment
ensemble aussi avec un nouveau nouvelle
dimension du capitalisme du ou de la
juste de la façon dont tout le monde est
d'une certaine façon sur davantage
surveiller quand on donne pleins pleins
dont donne pleins pleins d'informations
il ya des il ya des entreprises qui
utilisent ces informations a souvent
c'est pour vendre de la publicité mais
ça peut être pour faire d'autres choses
et donc ce côté surveillance et ce côté
un exemple dans le truc de 2,2 dans les
questions de surveillance pro
probablement que les les systèmes de
reconnaissance faciale
on dirait on devrait s'en méfier les
données sont quelque part les visages
sont là le fait qu'il puisse y avoir une
caméra qui avec un pape d'identifier qui
relie un système et qui est capable
d'identifier n'importe qui ça va quand
même vraiment à l'encontre du droit
fondamental à la vie privée donc là la
reconnaissance faciale c'est pour ouvrir
ton cellulaire parce que la caméra voit
que c'est toi que ces personnes d'autres
encore que l'on pourrait imaginer les
scénarios
voilà le tut tut tut tut coupe la tête
d'une personne et puis tu l'as tu le
mets pour que son cellulaire s'allume
avec la reconnaissance faciale donc mais
bon ça sale explique cela c'est quand
même facile d'imaginer que le jeu
rampant dans la conspiration le circuit
c'est quand même facile d'imaginer que
ces données-là de reconnaissance faciale
sont quelque part dans une dans une
banque de données
il y en a plusieurs en fait parce que
toutes les photos tous composent cc
récupérer quand tu pars départ des data
c'est facile d'imaginer que avec des
caméras de surveillance partout mettons
à la sono métro on peut savoir qu' aucun
facile d'imaginer ceci s il ya des
caméras comme c'est le cas je pars à
londres il ya des caméras partout en
chine y des régions ci a beaucoup
beaucoup de caméras ont les gens sont
plus aussi anonymes cas vraiment la
possibilité de l'est de les traquer et
ça c'est pas sur ce genre de société
qu'on a envie de dans lequel on a envie
d'être là donc ouais il ya des effets il
ya des il ya des
il ya des potentiels négatifs là à ces
développements technologiques ce qu'est
la technologie votre trop rapidement
pour l'éthique est ce qu'on a le temps
de réfléchir vraiment aux impacts pillot
bien pu mal de toutes ces questions le à
la vitesse la technologie revente qui
avance qui est vraiment rapide
en fait moi comme un philosophe plonger
dans ce monde la laddh et des nouvelles
technologies jeu c'est clair que je sens
le c'est pas la même vitesse là il ya il
ya un truc du côté de la philosophie la
ccba collecte si on prend plusieurs mois
voire plusieurs années à écrire un
article à lire et alors que dans le
monde de la technologie et on est dans
les startups les jeunes pousses et puis
y'a donc il ya quand même un clash
quelques calculs quelque part parce que
ces deux de temporalité après ce qu'on
l'a échappé je suis pas je suis pas sûr
je pense est encore possible de
de réguler mettons d'interdire la
reconnaissance faciale à sion juste que
c'est vraiment vraiment mal mais ouais
ça ça oblige en tout cas il ya un besoin
d'eux
il ya un besoin de réflexion éthique un
peu plus urgent que qui a 50 ans quoique
même il ya tout le temps besoin de
d'éthique mais c'est vrai que ça peut
être ça peut aller vite et qu'il faut il
faut être allumé il faut surveiller mais
toi mais tu en as réfléchissant ces
questions le puits avec des collègues
quand vous arrivez metrakit telles
nouvelles technologies ou telle chose a
devrait être régulier de telle façon
pour pékin et de débordement ou des
dérives éthiques
ce qui est apprécié à vous apporter ce
aux gens qui font vraiment les lois pic
si vous êtes entendus ou pas plus que ça
mais il ya des il ya des mécanismes y
apprit attiyah des comités d'éthique par
exemple il ya la cst cayla au québec la
commission sur l'éthique des sciences et
des technologies
je suis dans un de leur comité
donc là on peut faire des propositions
assez précises au législateur comme on
dit en tout cas aux personnes qui est
gouverne qu'il ya oui il ya il ya quand
même décider des systèmes qui sont la
méga pas disons que moi ce qui me
le manque que je vois c'est comme c'est
l'éthique de l'intelligence artificielle
ou l'éthique des algorithmes comme celle
des disciplines vraiment jeune
il n'y a pas encore encore oubliée aussi
bien structuré que des domaines comme
l'éthique animale ou l'éthique
environnementale où est l'éthique pour
les pour les humains donc il ya encore
beaucoup beaucoup de travail à faire si
vous êtes philosophe ou si vous êtes
juste intéressés par la philo et
l'éthique ça vaut vraiment la peine de
regarder ça et il ya du travail pour les
cerveaux qui voudront réfléchir à sa
main parce que des questions d'éthique
d'algorithmes par exemple des réseaux
sociaux le tir par exemple facebook le
dire des questions éthiques qui se pose
le pied à ce niveau là sur le des
informations sur toutes sortes sur le
fait d'être justement plus on est attiré
vers certains sites d'information
certains propos plus c'est ce qui nous
faisait pousser centenaire encombrement
de de l'information qui est factuelle
qui est qui va l'aider pile heure on
arrive à un point où est ce que il ya
une question qui se pose est est d'un
côté s qui on est ce qu'on censure je
mets des guillemets certaines
informations certaines idées de parce
que sont les juges qui sont pas factuel
versus contenus qu'ils soient répandues
mais que ça amène d'autres
d'autres problèmes en société puis après
ce est-ce qu en tant qu eto o télé je
sais pas à quel point c'est réguler seul
algorithme et de facebook du sommet je
crois pas qu'ils aient beaucoup de
réglementation si vous voulez une
entreprise privée qui s'auto réguler
mais ils ont fait des faits des progrès
là maintenant ils ont un genre de
cour suprême pour les cas vraiment
litigieux de personnes qui sont fait
bannir outre en tenue qui sont fait
bannir gérard un tram qui se fait bannir
le facebook - qu'est-ce que c'est
acceptable ou pas donc ils ont
conscience qu'ils aient ce genre de
d'enjeux mes rêves
reste qu' il me semble que c'est quand
même sous sous-exploré on y réfléchit
pas assez parce que c'est ça ressemble
un peu à facebook un sujet sur lequel je
réfléchirai bien souvent c'est youtube
maintenait ou qui donc un algorithme
donc ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
c'est il ya plus de recherche
actuellement sur youtube que sur google
donc les par heure la yale il ya plus de
vidéos qui sont regardés à une recherche
sur google à ses 2 milliards
d'utilisateurs qui regardent en moyenne
une demi-heure de youtube par jour et
donc ces gros la tripote lens est ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que 70% des
contenus regardé par les gens sur
youtube vient directement de
l'algorithme des recommandations comme
sûr je passe une magnifique en a tout le
temps on est dans un monde où on reçoit
des commandes et passent leurs commandes
est plein de talent et c'est des
recommandations individuel c'est des
recommandations moi je me fais pas
recommander la même chose que toi ô toi
donc et puis ça il ya qu un algorithme
est capable de faire ça deux pour chaque
personne individuellement d'établir
qu'elle est là c'est que c'est quoi les
vidéos que moussa sur lesquels tu vas tu
vas triper mais salah ce ce pouvoir de
l'algorithme il est extrêmement fort en
fait parce que ça veut dire que si la
halle berry qui te recommande une vidéo
anti vaccins mettons
tut tut tut ou qu'il te recommande pas
une vie une vidéo anti vaccin ça peut
faire une différence très très très très
forte sur a prêté des croyances sur les
sur les vaccins donc là il ya une
responsabilité morale très fort
youtube a un peu évolué d'ailleurs je
pense que maintenant ils ont ils
recommandent plus de vidéos elles sont
pas interdites mais elles sont plus
recommandés mais pendant longtemps et
les algorithmes de youtube recommander
des vidéos conspirationnistes
recommander des vidéos anti vaccin parce
que la seule chose qui était programmé
dans l'algorithme s'était fait plus
effet fait plaisir aux halles à la
personne puis les personnes qui tombe
sur une vidéo conspirationnistes ou anti
vaccins il ya quelque chose dans la
d'excitant il ya quelque chose
d'intéressant c'est c'est différent de
ce que l'on ya un côté un peu addictif
pilar l'algorithme vois que tu as
regardé la première vidéo en entier dont
quittant présente une deuxième une
troisième et cetera il ya vraiment des
gens qui ont été convaincues par des
théories conspirationnistes mettant à
cause de l'algorithme de youtube avant
ça il était parfaitement sain du tu te
scientifique bornes l'aï lavé mais là le
rythme les a amenés dans un trou comme
ça donc il ya une responsabilité me
semble-t-il forte de
de youtube mais qui est qu'il a comme
ceux qui commencent à la prendre un
petit peu mais qui la prend pas
complètement on pourrait aussi se
demander voilà ce que ça fait du sens de
faire de dans une société où il ya une
crise climatique qui s'en vient de que
les l'algorithme de youtube te
recommande des vidéos de viande mettons
des vidéos de ces super prendre l'avion
ou achète toi un gros char qui va qui va
polluer donc il ya vraiment une
une responsabilité diffuse de c2c
halloween et c'est un sujet qui est
difficile à dont il est difficile de
parler parce qu'encore une fois moi mon
youtube il est super là je suis content
là oui parce que c'est ce que c'est que
des choses pour moi mais moi je ne vois
pas les vidéos il s'agira sioniste ou
anti vaccins on n'a pas du tout on a on
n'a plus comme l'espace commun et pour
pour faire de la politique il faut
savoir ce que les gens ce qu'est ce que
les autres voient faut savoir c'est ça
l'avantagé au moins des médias
traditionnels cinéma mon côté la même
télé journaux arbres et moi-même jardin
exactement là où chacun même les pubs
qu'on voit son
sont individualisés là je sais pas les
pubs que vous vous voyez donc honnie au
niveau démocratie au niveau décident
ensemble de ce qui est bien pour nous ça
favorise pas les choses donc un truc
comme l'algorithme de youtube aurait
sans doute besoin d'être il est déjà
régulés parce qu'on voit en fait on voit
pas tout sur youtube il ya des
modérateurs les trucs extrêmement
violent la pornographie c'est c'est
éliminer mais on fait on fait des
catégories puis en tout cas jusqu'à
récemment considéré que des des vidéos
conspirationnistes sa cellule mais
accepte non seulement acceptable mais
comment il recommandé reste qu'au final
c'est des entreprises privées à but
lucratif le dit donc que l'algue répit
et à pâques les on le connaît peu le
connaissent à l'inter mais nous je dois
savoir et comme le fonctionnement
exactement de tous se piler le but de le
but recherché par l'algorithme qu'on le
connaît mal typique il ya une aussi du
grand pouvoir une si grande
responsabilité dans quelque chose qu'on
ne sait plus de contrôler un peu mais
oui c'est peas est effectivement cessé
ça manque de transparence est une
entreprise
privé après on pourrait on pourrait
imaginer qu'elle décide d'être voilà le
le fait qu'elle ait décidé d'arrêter de
recommander les vidéos anti vaccins ou
conspirationnistes roughol c'est quand
même un pas vers l'avant
la pression je m'en sers dans des cas
précis on peut choix de s'adapter
ouais ouais c'est fascinant où est-ce
qu'on a maintenant qu'on veut suivre un
peu ce que tu fais est une façon de le
faire pour les gens qui nous écoutent on
peut évidemment acheter une wii donc là
le dernier c'est voir son steak nom
s'est prononcée faire la morale aux aux
robes on peut l'acheter où il est il est
disponible aussi en bibliothèque même
ans il voulait pas sortir en livre
électronique dans les bibliothèques
j'ai découvert ça pendant la pandémie
ses bas ses bas coût un cadeau moi aussi
j'ai fait
donc ce livre s'il voir son steak comme
un animal mort le précédent qui est
aussi disponible en bibliothèque ou à ou
à l'achat puis je suis co rédactrice en
chef d'ing
mais d'une revue en ligne qui s'appelle
l' amorce revue contre le spécisme don
qui est une région va dire intello las
pour réfléchir à la société mais avec
cet angle de spe 6 mai puis droits des
animaux alors on peut on publier pas
beaucoup c'est peut-être remplir au
maximum un article par par semaine mais
j'écris régulièrement la dent puis sinon
il ya tout simplement mon site web
martin gilbert pointe comme où il ya
tous les tous les articles que j'ai
publié oui j'ai un blog aussi qui
s'appelle la quatrième blessure ou je
m'intéresse aux enjeux des tic dans
l'intelligence artificielle donc l'
amorce et la quatrième blessure on
s'enligne c'est le plus simple qu'on
veut dire c'est super merci beaucoup et
bien parlé merci d'avoir écouté ce
podcast jusqu'à la fin de ce pas que
vous avez apprécié la conversation ça
prouve que vous êtes de réelles fans de
conversation et sans fil pas de casser
on vous remercie vraiment beaucoup
si vous voulez voir plus de contenus
plus de conversations sur pétillante que
ça se passe bien sûr peut tuer a non
seulement on met tous les podcasts en
ligne au moment où est ce qu'on les
tombes donc on a beaucoup de semaine
d'avant sur le pétrole mais on fait
aussi des encore moins de filtres qui
sont exclusifs au monde pictural ou est
ce que on parle d'homme nicole et moi de
la conversation combien d'abord parce
qu'on met un peu plus en profondeur dans
certains sujets complets abordés ou
qu'on a abordé pendant le podcast donc
allez sur une page de turenne les liens
vers ses avoirs dans la description du
podcast qui remercie encore une fois de
nous avons écouté jusqu'à la fonte